the other day
time magazine published an article
discussing
the secret campaign to save
the 2020 election yes that's right save
and i'm going to use only the words they
used in the article
they say it was a shadow campaign that
it literally they say
it was a conspiracy and the definition
of conspiracy is
people getting together in secret for an
unlawful or harmful act
straight up they say that it was an
elite cabal of
industrialists and special interests and
political elites and media elites
who came together to affect every aspect
of the election from changing the rules
changing the laws controlling the flow
of information
what would you call it if you were say
going to compete in some kind of
athletic event
and then your opponent got all of the
rules changed to help them
would you consider that to have been a
rigged event many people probably would
but they say they weren't rigging the
event they were
fortifying it for the quote proper
outcome no joke this whole article
basically is like
they're they name names they're proud of
it they're cheering for it they say they
saved the country they saved democracy
subverting the will of the people
through manipulation changing the rules
and they did it for over a year and they
go through
every detail about how they did it now
some of the stuff is innocuous they're
like we were fighting for voter rights
and it's like that i get
changing laws controlling the flow of
information and
lobbying big tech companies to suppress
what they deem
to be misinformation of course most of
you know that doesn't include russiagate
or
things like that so it's a crazy day
it's a it's
it's a crazy day we got a ton of news we
got that story we've got bank of america
people are now boycotting they're
calling for a major boycott because
bank of america is giving your private
financial information to the feds
without just straight up violating the
fourth amendment i mean not really
that's the point
the private corporations are are being
the government is outsourcing
constitutional violations
to major corporations there's a bunch of
stuff going on that just has me feeling
like
i don't know things are getting just
outright crazy and so we're going to
talk about these pretty big subjects
we have a great guest tonight to help us
go through this we have jack pasobic
how's it going man hey hey what's going
on
just introduce yourself i'm sure people
are familiar yeah sure jack posobik uh
hear from one american news
correspondent there
at uh at washington d.c currently in the
occupied green zone
of washington dc or right there on
constitution ave
which of course we'll be talking about
january 6 a little bit most recently
got into it a little bit this week with
alexandria ocasio-cortez congresswoman
um who you know i i tweeted an article
about and she decided to
try to put a target on my back didn't go
very well for her everything
you you tweeted a simple sentence was
not at the capitol one sentence
that she was like how dare you it's like
you didn't even you didn't that's true
you know but it's
just a true statement it's it's not
really you know anything so
we'll talk about that too because now
she's grandstanding and this is like it
became a really big story because
she just keeps doubling down now she
sent an email to her constituents saying
go online and flag anyone who dare
oppose me yeah after it became
the number one trend nationwide
twice with first alexandria
ocasio-smollette
and then second aoc lied neither of
which i take credit
for they organically kind of came up uh
for people making the connection between
jesse smilet
and her response to all of this was not
to take it in stride
was not to and this is why it actually
matters and this is why you know they
say
you know we we need to dial up the noise
not the signal not the noise right
so i'm going to give you signal that
noise here is that she is trying to
weaponize
this situation we saw what she she was
one of the leaders
of parlor the d platforming of parlor
going to amazon putting pressure on them
now leading to deep platform twitter
users
facebook users whatever it is just for
correcting her for criticizing her and
again
this isn't this is different than when
you know
one of those sort of fake news
apparatchiks comes out there and says oh
this dangerous person is always
spreading
you know you know they're the a
different opinion on the internet
this is a you federal u.s official
who lied who lied definitively
definitively i would say that as a
statement of fact
full credit to you for actually blowing
that wide apart because
i tweeted the map but then when you went
to that timeline
i think you you broke the case yeah she
like blows straight up the entire thing
out of the wall well let's
we'll get into all that soon yeah for
sure for sure but that was a huge major
thing i'm in the new york post this week
i'm all over this week on that
i know right hey there you go it's crazy
to me that i'm seeing and here we are
ben shapiro and a bunch of other people
it's like the argument is still wrong
they're like well maybe she didn't lie
but she wasn't in the building and i'm
like no no the timeline
it was a full hour before there was a
capital breach no one knew was going to
happen she lied but we'll get into we'll
get into it i don't get carried away
we got sean i'm very excited jack is
here he's a former
intel navy officer who was at gitmo so
i'm very excited
jack for you to tell us how the gulags
are going to be for all of us
we used to joke about that but now it's
like oh there we go
yeah yeah here we are welcome back
beautiful and amazing human beings my
name is lucadowski of we are change.org
and if you want to find me
you could find me tweeting up a storm on
luke we are change and memeing up a
storm on
instagram also under luke we are changed
thanks for having me
we got ian and he's wearing a we are
change shirts i just got my new shirt
everyone check it out
i like it you can get this shirt at uh
the best political shirts.com thank you
you heard it here first and uh along
what you were saying with
um something about private companies
handling some of this sensitive stuff i
just read an article yesterday that the
government will have like
private organizations do a lot of the
high-tech stuff so that freedom of
information
act requests you can't get it because
they're with private organizations
it's clever glad you're here jack really
good to be on the show with you man
can't even afford it there we go we got
sarpatuli she's pressing all the time
i'm pressing all the buttons right on
so before we get into this big breaking
story my friends you must do one very
important thing go to timcast.com and
become a member
we have a really cool bonus segment from
the other night
where the navy claims to have tech that
can quote engineer the fabric of reality
space flight warp drive wondering if
it's legit because there are some
questions but
we set this up because we're going to be
talking about how
an elite cabal so saith time magazine
conspired and that's according time
magazine
to steve to fortify the election
by changing the rules laws and
manipulating the flow of information and
lobbying big tech to suppress
information
that's all according to a mainstream
publication now that's the kind of
conversation that results in us
um you know just being put at risk for
nasty platforming
cassandra fairbanks if you're not
familiar with her she is a journalist
over at the gateway pundit i
always do this every time i bring them
up i don't i'm not a fan of the gateway
pundit
but i know in trust cassandra and she
published footage
of vans showing up to the tcf center in
detroit
that's a vote mobile on them that was it
and she got suspended on twitter for it
well there you go i mean you can't even
have these conversations
but we can have them over at timcast.com
so become a member because we will have
more bonus segments more exclusive
members only content coming up
let's jump to the news and don't forget
to like subscribe hit the notification
bell
and uh what's the other one am i
forgetting leave a comment leave a
comment comment and uh super chat
and share with your friends ladies and
gentlemen i bring you to
time magazine saying the quiet part loud
no not actually i i take that back we'll
explain the secret
history of the shadow campaign that
saved
the 2020 election no joke
i'm tracking straight up they say trump
was right there was
okay i am reading i'm gonna read to you
from time magazine
trump was right there was a conspiracy
unfolding behind the scenes
one that both curtailed the protests and
coordinated the resistance from ceos
both surprises were the result of an
informal alliance between left-wing
activists
and business titans the democrats
major corporations and ceos formed what
i guess you could call a
lucrative merger between corporation and
state for the purpose of winning
political power
is there a word for something like that
the word's fascist oh fascists
oh is that is that the word let's just
cut to the chase yeah
okay i was just about to swear don't do
it
the handshake between business and labor
was just one
component of a vast cross-partisan
campaign
but the best part is just just jumping
down because they really are
quite uh wordy in this let me read this
for you yeah no kidding this is the
inside story of the
conspiracy to save the 2020 election
based on access to the group's inner
workings
never before seen documents and
interviews with dozens of those involved
from across the political spectrum
i'm going to stop right there and tell
you that conspiracy implies a crime
in in in law it does and the general
definition
is unlawful or harmful act a group
acting in secret
for an unlawful or harmful outcome
they go on to say it is the story of an
unprecedented creative and determined
campaign
whose success also reveals how close the
nation came to disaster
every attempt to interfere with the
proper outcome of the election was
defeated
the proper outcome of the election
interesting word
what does that mean i love this article
i love everything about this artist
i love it the way it's written a huge
molly ball right
yeah i want to buy her dinner wow i love
it check it out uh
but they say quote but it's massively
important for the country to understand
that it didn't happen accidentally
the system didn't work magically
democracy is not self-executing
that's why the participants want the
secret history of the 2020 election told
even though it sounds like a paranoid
fever dream a well-funded okay i'm gonna
stop right now my friends
i am reading you verbatim from time.com
time magazine these are not my words a
well-funded cabal of powerful people
ranging across
industries and ideologies working
together behind the scenes to influence
perceptions
change rules and laws steer media
coverage
and control the flow of information they
were not rigging the election they were
fortifying it
and they believe the public needs to
understand the system's fragility
in order to ensure that democracy in
america
endures i'll make it very clear for you
you are not
saving democracy when you conspire
behind the scenes
with powerful industrialists ceos and
the elites
to subvert the flow of information and
prevent
the the improper outcome as so you as as
you see it
the true outcome is to sit back advocate
for your candidate advocate for your
ideas
and then hope people vote for you what
they did
very much sounds like it was criminal
and i'll tell you why
many i believe that the number right now
is 24 states
changed their election rules without
going through state legislatures now
illegal is very different statutory law
is different from constitutional law so
i shouldn't say criminal i'll just put
it this way it was a conspiracy to
violate the constitution
to stop donald trump from winning to
steer media coverage control the flow of
information
change rules and laws prior to an
election just as our founding fathers
that's right created friends i remember
it was uh
it was uh who was it uh who said give me
liberty or give me death patrick
so he was this was in virginia and they
were having you know this in house
delegates
yes yes yes and they were trying to
determine whether to join the revolution
and he stood up and said
give me liberty well asterisks will come
back to that or give me death now what i
meant by that was
we want to make sure the rabble can't be
in control of these elections you know
so we as the powerful elites want to
actually manipulate them into thinking
they have the power and
give me that and then maybe i'm willing
to die for it that's exactly how it went
fortifying is also a very interesting
word here and also the timing
why now did time and i want to say this
too
admit that there was a secret cabal of
powerful wealthy elites that were
working with corporations steering media
coverage influence perceptions and
changing their rules to get their way
time said that not me don't get me in
trouble why now
did this happen and when you look at
those kind of other statements you're
seeing some rebuttals here
and the rebuttals here rebuttals here
are that it was done in public there was
this was
sort of transparent but but even if it
was it still doesn't make it
a good thing and when we look at what
actually happened
this election specifically with the
hunter biden story
especially with some of the primaries in
the democratic
uh you know presidential run up you see
a lot of foul playing
you see a lot of things that shouldn't
have happened but did
and they're wrong the hunter biden
cover-up story that's the biggest one
and to what you're saying and we want to
be clear about this because the article
does this as well
and even with something we'll talk about
later the timeline
matters right going through the timeline
this article is important because they
don't lay this out in a chronological
fashion
you get about three quarters of the way
through this article i've read it twice
it's about 6 500 words
and about three quarters of the way
through
they admit that this was something they
were working on
in october and november of 2019 because
remember we're all told we were all sold
on this well we had to do changes we had
to change the system because of covet
19.
forget the fact that dr fauci actually
came out and berks came out
and said oh you actually can safely vote
in person they said that
as long as you're doing this social
distancing six feet you're wearing a
mask
perfectly fine same as you know going to
walmart anyways it is obviously an
essential
uh an essential act that you want to be
performing so dr fauci came out and said
that
but no no no we were told now this it
can't be done the workers have to be
there all day
we can't allow this to happen we've got
to do the mail-in voting we've got to do
universal voting
send ballots everywhere ballots all over
the place in many of these states
and they were planning to do this even
before the word
covid crossed anyone's lips in the west
back when even before china started
arresting the physicians out in wuhan
right they were already planning to
change the system to get
what they said the appropriate outcome
proper
the problem uh the mainland voting
change
in pennsylvania happened in october of
october well before
it happened and i remember i didn't i
didn't realize that and so i saw this
lawsuit pop up and then i started
researching it and i was like wait
wait they passed mail in voting in
october i thought mainland voting was
being passed because of covid
no it was part of a elite cabal
plan according to time magazine and they
actually say this mail in voting to get
people to vote for by mail for the first
time
it was part of their plan now i'll be
i'll be honest
i mean we knew this i have how many
videos where i said the democrats are
rigging the election
and what i said was they're not doing
anything they're changing the rules
at the last minute in order to benefit
themselves we had sean parnell on the
show and he said
they're changing the rules because it's
going to help them win
so it's funny you could say they broke
the rules but they changed the rules
beforehand
so no rules were actually broken except
maybe the constitution which is a big
rule
but the problem with that with that is
that the court cases all got through
neither standing or latches so i made a
mistake on twitter i said
that the the uh vote by mail rule was
unconstitutional at the state and
federal level
and it was a a lower court judge said
that
the the plaintiffs so this is sean
parnell and i think mike kelly
would have won on the merit uh that
mail-in voting is not allowed
universally in pennsylvania because they
have rules about how you know you can do
absentee ballots it's our state
constitution right right right but
it got sent to the higher court the
state supreme court who threw it out
not on the merit but on latches right
which means you
filed this lawsuit way too late it's
over goodbye right so here's here's the
catch-22 on all of that and i say this
as
i i'm you know pennsylvania kid
philadelphia area
that so the pennsylvania state supreme
court right now is currently controlled
by a super majority of democrats
and what they did was they were saying
okay doctrine of latches that means
too much time has gone by we can't fix
this
therefore there's no way to actually uh
remunerate
what's been done to you and so we're
going to have to let this slide there's
no way to redo the election it's kind of
what they're saying
but at deshaun parnell's point i've
spoken with him on this as well
had he brought that case prior to the
election
they would say you do not have standing
because you have yet to be injured
exactly so if the catch 22 becomes you
can't have
you can't file suit prior you can't file
suit
after when are you supposed to do it in
the middle of the day on election day it
doesn't make
any sense and you've written this in
such a way where
you this is and this is why people love
lawyers so much that
you know you've cut you've created a
situation where there is no way to find
relief from this
they co here's what they they need to do
they needed to have sued immediately
and then when they said you have no
injury then they could have sued and
said ah
look at that one and that would have at
least been their leg to stand on we
tried
you said standing we now have injury
we're back
and then they would have to be like oh
well they can't cite latches because i
already tried sued and now that we're
injured
however they might have said that they
may they probably would have said the
same thing oh well it's been a year
now so it's too long the law has been
put in place blah blah blah
i want to read something to you guys
from the article this is the craziest
the craziest aspect of this
which i think is one of the most
demoralizing sentences you'll probably
hear
their work touched every aspect of the
election they got states to change
voting systems
and laws and help secure hundreds of
millions in public and private funding
you ready for the next one they fended
off voter suppression laws well
i'm sorry they fended off voter
suppression lawsuits
recruited armies of poll workers and got
millions of people to vote by mail for
the first time
i would like to see an investigation
into what that sentence means
what do you mean they recruited poll
workers they were poll workers who were
in this cabal
in this conspiracy according time
magazine let me slow it down for you
guys
time magazine said there was a
conspiracy to
uh to produce the proper outcome they
recruited
poll workers it's in the article i'm
gonna show you one more time it says
they recruited armies of poll workers
what were they doing
what were those poll workers doing as
part of this conspiracy where's what are
the sources of this
article they have the names they have
the people on record everyone's named on
record
there's from the afl-cio uh the not the
president but the senior adviser to the
president
there's people involved from numerous
progressive leftist center organizations
um a ton of people from these you know
protect democracy type groups like norm
eisen ian bessen is someone who
has also been named in there a lot of
the same people by the way who were
pushing
the russia gate lawsuits running a lot
of the websites that had to do with
russiagate
i mean all those ones that sort of
started bubbling up in around late 2017
early 2018 suddenly shifted mueller came
out that didn't work the report
they shifted suddenly and then starting
in 2019
they were all talking about this
election
uh what they called protection voter
protection
right and again to use that phrase
there's a lot of editorializing in this
article as well and i hope people
understand that while they're reading
this that
they call it an election suppression law
well an election suppression law if you
have a different
perspective on it it might be something
called an election integrity law
election right having somebody check
your signature doing a signature match
that's not suppression
they call it suppression that's not
that's making sure that that that's the
real person that's actually signing up
checking id
this is not suppression this is making
sure you are the real person but they
will
call it suppression as a way of saying
oh you're trying to disenfranchise
people no
we're trying to make sure that elect
look i'm a veteran a lot of people are
veterans we always talk about
our democracy is the most important
thing in this country well shouldn't we
take it seriously and not allow
shadowy cabals to be able to come in and
control the flow of information and laws
so so editorializing right
they come out they say voter suppression
and disinformation disinformation
literally just means
information from your perspective you
could say it's fake news
someone else could say it's not it's
literally suppressing just
information whether you like it or not
it could be disinformation sure i'm not
a fan
well actually you should you should
point out that you are now
disinformation
i am well no because of uh uh twitter
has declared that you were right
it was i tweeted i i put out a snarky
tweet
where i said uh so okay so let me slow
down cassandra fairbanks
uh put out a story about they actually
have the video footage
i've seen the footage you can see it
online it's vans that say vote mobile on
them
pulling up to the tcf center actually
let me let me slow down
i'm not going to assert i know what this
is i'm not going to say it's one thing
or another i'm going to tell you what
the video shows
a black car pulls up at the tcf center
and a man walks up and it looks as
though something may be exchanged
their hands come together after this
happens
a van pulls up that says vote mobile on
it it's a white van and they begin
unloading big boxes
and this happens apparently several
times cassandra fairbanks put this story
out and i responded i quote tweeted it
saying i'm not sure this matters
they've time magazine already admitted
they rigged the election
i'm sorry they said they didn't rigged
the election they quote
fortified it by changing rules and laws
and manipulating the flow of information
now manipulated is my editorialization
but it was
almost verbatim changing rules and laws
controlling the flow of information was
what they said
twitter restricted the tweet claiming
that i put out
disinformation that could lead to
violence well that's a false statement
to fact they say this claim is disputed
i guess technically that's true because
well actually no it's not true if time
magazine is saying it who's disputing it
is the left disputing time magazine's
claim about the story
they're not no conservative is the
conservatives are going i knew it
so who's disputing it there's it's a
false statement effect
no one is disputing it well so what does
twitter do to your tweet you can't like
you can't share you can't retweet you
can't respond you can't do anything
you can quote tweet it i've got some
breaking news for you actually yeah so i
think you're gonna appreciate this so
i actually know some people that got in
that got accepted
into the bird watch program do you guys
know about this bird watch
so birdwatch is this new community
sourced
um fact-checking ability that it's an
add-on to twitter
now right now you can't see it publicly
because they're still kind of in beta
mode
but it goes into individual tweets and
then you can market
hey this was this is unhelpful this is
helpful this is misleading this is not
misleading right
so my friend who's in bird watch sent me
your tweet tim
and i can actually see from the link on
the inside of it every single person
who's marked it so far
has wrote not misleading not misleading
not misleading not
not misleading yeah he literally has it
on his phone that's great
that's amazing that's like that uh not
misleading not misleading
not misleading not so birdwatch has your
back can i can i
can i can i quote some of these uh yeah
you might want to take out the uh i'm
not gonna say their names or anything
yeah yeah so what what jack has just
showed me i i i've i've never seen this
before
this is twitter's fact checking this is
birdwatch bird watch what it looks like
on the inside
and i'm going to read you my my tweet is
locked
right now i just checked you can't share
it you can't comment you can't do
anything you can quote to you so
let me do this let me uh try and pull
how do we do this
let me pull up my other phone all right
this is fun i'm gonna i'm gonna read you
what i said and what they said
i said i don't think this even matters
at this point
time magazine just came out and said the
that a cabal of elites rigged the
election
i'm sorry they said they didn't rigged
the election they quote fortified it by
changing the rules and laws as well as
manipulating the flow of information
below it twitter included this this
claim of election fraud is disputed
and this tweet can't be replied to
retweeted or liked due to a risk of
violence
jack is showing me bird watch i have it
my hand not misleading
according to the officiat officiating
source of time there was a
well-organized group of secret
participants
in a shadow organization that sounds
like a cabal that worked together to
sway the election in favor of joe biden
another post not misleading he's
referring to this and a link to the
story
another post not misleading the tweet is
a direct quote from time magazine
not misleading a link to the story
another and one more
not misleading while tim poole used the
word rigged where time euphemistically
is fortified the information conveyed in
his tweet is factual with respect to
times reporting
there you go and they have still
restricted my tweet
so i personally reached out to jack
dorsey
and said twitter has published a false
statement of fact
uh on my tweet and i would like twitter
to remove it and
issue a statement correcting the record
and then i sent him a link to the time
magazine story which by the way
they're not only claiming that you're
misleading they're
think of this they're claiming that your
tweet is a potential
incitement of violence or creates the
risk over creates the risk of violence
they're also saying that i claimed there
was fraud i didn't
i didn't say fraud you definitely didn't
say fraud and the tweet is is about
the the cabal and rigging doesn't mean
illegal and rigging doesn't in fact you
actually said
that if you want to go to the next level
on this cassandra's tweet
was claiming fraud but your tweet was
saying no hers wasn't either
i thought it was the the video cassandra
tweeted
here is the video we found of a quote
vote mobile van arriving at 3 30 a.m and
4 30 a.m
driving directly into the tcf center and
unloading dozens of boxes each trip
this was eight hours after the ballot
deadline her tweet doesn't say they were
boxes of ballots
okay she said unloading boxes unloading
box and then she added the context the
ballot of the ballot deadline
now you can argue my point is your tweet
though you were basically saying it
doesn't even matter
right so you're even downplaying her
potential tweet
right but but even still they added a
flag on cassandra's tweet
and they suspended her but that tweet
which is the one that i believe that's
the one that got her suspended
she didn't say they were unloading boxes
of ballots no she said a vote mobile van
showed up and was unloading boxes she
accurately described what was in the
video
exactly exactly which we can all see i
watched the video myself and i thought
this is interesting i'd like to i'd like
an investigation to know what was going
on here
is this normal how does it work in that
county is this a
you know what what what is it right what
is it i'd like to you know the problem
is
not a not not one of these i'll do air
quotes journalists and any of these
major publications will go near it
they won't even watch the video they
won't do it right one of the big
problems that that people have
even prior to the time magazine uh
you know confession letter came out is
that people have been asking
you know honest people i think have been
asking what level of transparency is
there in our elections
how can we be sure you know we all went
to bed seeing one thing
and then over the next few days that
result kept changing
so shouldn't we as a country want to be
in a situation where 47 48 whatever it
is percent of people
at least agree with the outcome the fact
that it was gotten to
fairly that the process was fair that
there was transparency but every time
you ask the question
you get shot down you get yelled down
you get shouted you get scolded you get
you know suspended on twitter or flagged
on twitter
and then and then time magazine comes
out and we get the shadowy cabal
we got ocean's eleventh donald trump got
ocean's eleven but we all got oceans
eleven a long time ago
all right i say i say that that's how i
describe donald trump was in the
election
as we can now see from the admission of
time magazine they were working out rule
changes
for over a year to make sure that
everything was slanted as heavy as
possible
away from trump and they even say in the
article they were worried because trump
was still
outperforming the polls after everything
they conspired to do
i'm going to stress this one more time
because i all want you to hear it
the story says that there was a
conspiracy of a cabal
well-funded and powerful that recruited
armies of
pole workers just think about what that
means that's time magazine saying that
okay
and and i think this is this is key i
don't know if you mentioned this part
yet
that it actually talks about how it's
the u.s chamber of commerce
working with the afl-cio so this is your
you know the workers and the owners
actually
shaking hands for the first time saying
that usually you know the afl cio is
against the chamber of commerce that's
you know
the the unions donate to the democrats
the chamber of commerce donates to
republicans and then
they battle it out in congress that's
kind of the standard way
that politics has been done for the last
30 40 years
this time around it's like we're going
to join together because we have to do
everything to
ensure the proper outcome are you saying
the chamber of commerce
was involved with the cabal i'm saying
time magazine says that okay and
uh is chamber of commerce a federal uh
organization i don't think so
no no no they're no they're private or
they're not private non-profit okay are
there any federal organizations
uh indicted by time magazine i don't
know okay
i wouldn't say federal but certainly
state prominent obama administration
officials
recruited republicans into the program
so i think what it sounds like is that
some people know that it was about to
get blown the lid was about to get blown
off so they're trying to get ahead of
the story
and they're trying to do it before
sentiment fails for biden
that's that's that's one theory this is
a frame this is definitely a framing
device this story right right right so i
think that's that's one of the theories
that people
have been talking about but we were
talking before the show that it's
what i described it as returning to the
scene of the crime and
i think you jack you were mentioning
it's kind of like the letter from the
zodiac yeah this is
um what behavioral scientists would
refer to as
personation the idea that you leave a
signature because you desire you have
that sort of primal urge for credit
that to know that you did something and
you got away with it
and everyone in the world can see it and
yet
you don't have any credit for it no
social media
right um you know to go off of the the
scene of the crime you know btk
used to always write letters to the
newspaper or to
investigators to say taking credit for
his heinous crimes
if they got it wrong and say hey this
one was one of mine hey this one was one
of mine that could be one thing it could
be also what ian said they could be
getting ahead of something that's going
to be coming out
or they're just kind of fortifying what
a lot of people kind of knew was
happening already they knew that you
know the game was rigged
it serves many purposes yes and then we
were told that you know our system was
imperfect our system was vulnerable we
were told that for four years
individuals like john oliver the
mainstream media they were saying
there's problems with our elections that
was okay
was going to run kill chain they were
they were going to run
a documentary talking all about these
machines and
problems and they went out to
hackathon and we're talking all about
the issues because they were buying
these machines on ebay and going into
them which i never even knew about until
after the fact
and then they memory hold all of that
but now if you bring up
some of these problems you're going to
get censored you're going to get
memories it was the left that was
already seeding that narrative prior to
the election
and personally i think that was in case
they needed it they could go and say oh
look
this is what trump did just like the
dipole machines in ohio
with george w bush my friends i don't
think it matters at this point
time magazine can come out and gloat all
they want dc is occupied
they're surrounded by barbed wire fences
with five thousand nationals
razor wire razor not just barbed wire
razor wire
and it's going to be permanent right
there so the dc
homeland security advisor actually came
out and testified yesterday
in front of congress when they asked him
about this and he said you know we don't
need this to be permanent to secure dc
we actually don't secure dc hmm
well my friends i think we got bigger
things to worry about yeah
you want to know what those bigger
things are jack what if i were to tell
you that uh
you as a uh you you i'm i don't put
words in your mouth
i understand it's probably obvious but
you're a big trump supporter i was drum
sporter
absolutely yeah um uh what if they drown
strike you
you know the thing for me is when i turn
on msnbc
you see where we're going everybody we
got a story we got it and i watched
nicole wallace
and and you hear some of the words that
are coming out of these folks in mass
and it's amazing to me because
for all of 2020 this was the defund
police movement
and the cops in this country have it out
for
uh for the little guy and they're
they're you know proto-fascists of a
police state the harbingers
of totalitarianism and we need to go we
need to get rid of them
you even have people saying abolish the
entire not just private prisons
but the entire prison system but then
they'll turn around and say
except for any of you guys in a red
hat i want all of you down at guantanamo
bay
i want waterboarding i want drone
strikes everything that's been done
to al-qaeda should be done to you and
this was what brings us to the actual
segment and why i asked you
that question from the blaze msnbc host
suggests killing american citizens with
drone strikes
and another story which you brought up
jack from the nation
i'm for abolition and yet i want the
capital rioters
in prison they're not for abolition they
are tribalists
they view you as an evil other who must
be caged or exterminated
and i know that might sound extreme but
this woman on msnbc
literally said when we deal with
terrorists overseas i mean we
drone-strike these people like american
citizen
anwar al-awlaki and then they go on to
talk about americans
what do you think they're referring to
let me show you the story from the blaze
they say during a discussion regarding
domestic terror msnbc anchor nicole
wallace floated the idea
of the u.s government killing american
citizens with drone strikes
something they have done before several
times in fact under obama
wallace brought up the national terror
advisory system bulletin
that was released to all law enforcement
by the department of homeland security
last week
the ball 10 which is in effect until
april 30th warns the dhs allegedly
received information
that there is a threat of ideologically
motivated violent extremists
with objections to exercise objections
to the exercise of governmental
authority
and the presidential transition as well
as other perceived grievances fueled by
false narratives
could continue to mobilize to incite or
commit violence
wallace notes quote there's a bulletin
released to all law enforcement earlier
this week
that there is until the end of april a
persistent threat of domestic domestic
extremism
she goes on to mention that basically
what they are what they already said
that the cover restrictions are
unnecessary all of those id ideologies
pushed by trump
the deadline white house host then said
but my question for you is
around incitement we had a policy and it
was very controversial
it was carried out under the bush years
and under the obama years of attacking
terror at its route
of going after and killing and in the
case of anwar al-awlaki
an american yemeni-american with a drone
strike
for the crime of inciting violence
inciting terror wallace said
mitch mcconnell was in the senate then
he was in the senate after 9 11 2.
how does mitch mcconnell who understands
the way you root out terror
is to take it on in the case of islamic
terror kill those who incite it
how does he not vote to convict someone
that he said on the house floor incited
an insurrection
the blaze then quotes uh a very poor and
stupid journalist lucrative
uh hey hey hey the blaze then shows
luke's tweet
where he says so they are pretty much
saying they have to stop incitement of
violence by inciting violence themselves
yes this this is msnbc's nicole wall
this as
msnbc msnbc's nicole wall suggests we
use domestic drone strikes on americans
as a solution to lockdown protesters it
may sound extreme
but please listen to that quote she says
mitch mcconnell
understands the way you root out
terrorism is to take it on saying
in the previous sentence killing in the
case of anwar al-awlaki an american
humane american with a drone strike
there we are
i like how noah and mb msnbc even batted
an eye as she compared anti-lockdown
protesters to terrorists i mean are you
freaking kidding me and this is again
nicole wallace a former bush
spokesperson and it's very interesting
that she brought up anwar alawaki
because that's one american citizen
abdul rahim alawaki is yet another one
he's a 16 year old american citizen that
was killed
under of course barack obama's drone
bombing he was 16 years old
and then donald trump who personally
called for a raid
under his raid killed his daughter who
was eight years old so we have
literally the entire assassination of
this
family and and a lot of people are
i mean i remember when when this was
being codified i remember when this was
first introduced and i was screaming on
the top of my lungs
hey this is extremely dangerous we
cannot give
the right to kill anyone that power we
can't give that to the presidency
he can't be judge jury and executioner
this is dangerous and it's going to turn
against the american people and now
today we have them on national
television telling you that it's a good
thing abdul rahman al-awlaki was the
american people
he was a 16 year old american he was
born in denver colorado and he lived in
san diego
he was a teenager apparently he was
looking for his grandfather and went to
visit yemen
and obama for some reason ordered a
drone strike on a civilian restaurant
killing this 16 year old why yep they
said it was an accident we were
targeting someone else
did anyone then ask why did you drone
strike a civilian restaurant
even if it was to get this target in the
mainstream media no
but of course we we are changed we did
we we went after robert gibbs we went
after
obama's spokesperson his right hand man
and we and we cornered him and we asked
him a number of times why'd you do it
why'd you do it he finally snapped back
and you can see this in the we are
change video when you type in we are
changed robert gibbs he snapped back he
said
he should have had a better father that
was the official justification
when the when the obama administration
was even denying it happened
here's my favorite thing is that uh
obama had the disposition matrix which
was
informally known as the kill list and i
think it was debbie wasserman schultz
you asked
i was like she's like she's like the top
democrat for the dnc or whatever
and she was like what are you talking
about that doesn't exist no i asked her
i was like how do you feel about the
president potentially handing this power
to kill anyone at any moment
to potentially someone like mitt romney
she was like you're
crazy this doesn't exist what are you
talking about
peter king a republican called me an
absolute lunatic and a [ __ ] for even
believing that there was such a thing
no one even wanted to talk about this
thing and then now it's
here and now it's codified and now it's
being promoted as some kind of great
amazing glorious idea to deal with
anti-lockdown protesters this is this is
crazy
i mean that's real like
yeah i i i mean obviously i can't talk
too much about my
you know uh actual uh yeah you worked in
intelligence yeah yeah you know service
but yeah that's that's
very very real the story the story from
the new york times was that obama was
given what looked like baseball cards of
statistics and like age and a breakdown
and threat level and then he would be
like oh
kill him and uh well uh more like the
nfc
not not not necessarily obama himself he
would eventually have to sign off but it
would be the nsc
um going up and in some cases the
national security security council
um which is attached to the white house
they're in the eeob building but
it's it's a white house uh organ in a
sense and the nsc
was greatly expanded under barack obama
for purposes like this and barack obama
personally signed off
on a lot of these drone strikes
personally executing them
and he even came out a couple weeks ago
saying i kind of regret
being as aggressive as i was with
foreign policy because i was trying to
impress the republicans so i could look
tough in front of them
that sounds like a cop-out to say the
least especially when you have blood on
your hands and you killed american
citizens just
because of your signature well that's
killed american teenagers based on your
signature and again donald trump started
his presidency
not in a good way because he also
personally signed off on a raid
that killed his eight-year-old daughter
right that's right yeah the the the
well the eight-year-old sister of abdur
manalaki and the daughter oh and anwar
and not only were these
uh in some cases u.s citizens but
another k and you mentioned the
restaurant right you know the collateral
damage in some of these things there
were funerals
weddings i mean these these are clearly
one last thing
i need to add to this point because when
we look at these policies
syria iran uh you know afghanistan libya
they're all failed
but specifically when it comes to the
drone bombing campaign it came out
through many reports that over 90
of the drone bombs landed on unintended
people
killed innocent people that were not the
intended
targets so this is the program that they
want to bring back that they want to use
in the united states with a 90 percent
fail list
is kidding me i gotta add two two very
important things here luke the first is
you you were trying to call this out a
decade ago i mean this was like almost
this is nine years ago two thousand four
so
where you you have people who uh in the
government who are doing this
and the fear was that as they started
killing american citizens it would
eventually find its way
to american soil the government's been
empowered to do it and now here we are
yeah i mean ever since 2004 i was saying
the the war on terror is going to be uh
be going to be a war on the people and
that's exactly what we're seeing these
emergency laws being used now
turn against the american people the
only people who got this information out
there got my videos out there
where individuals like glenn greenwald
were the only few individuals that were
willing to share
these videos these confrontations with
robert gibbs with debbie wasserman
schultz with
peter king and all these other
individuals as the mainstream media
stayed silent on this issue
and even denied the fact that it existed
and now the other point i wanted to make
is that we recently heard from ken
cuccinelli that nancy pelosi wanted
crew served machine guns in dc
yeah what you need to understand about
the psychotic request
is that listen as most people who are
listening probably know
and many who are not big gun people
might not know all that well
it tends to be that those who are trying
to pass gun control laws know
nothing about guns and it becomes
particularly dangerous when they try
wielding them
because you end up with dumb people
saying things like fully semi-automatic
which is meaningless
or nancy pelosi saying automatically we
get
crew yeah automatically crew serve crew
served machine guns
in a civilian jurisdiction you know what
happens
when you fire a machine gun okay let me
ask you
what kind of bullet machine gun does she
wants well if their crew serve they're
probably going to be what like nato
rounds
or what five five six she's certainly
not saying 50 bmg full auto in dc is she
i think she was yeah regardless i don't
think she knows what she's talking about
let's two three seven six twos with the
mt40s m60s
and will those go through a person well
typically they're designed if you're
talking about the 50 cal that's designed
as an anti
it's the killer belt that's anti-armor
right so that's that's all
just just answer the questions yeah you
never really ever
see both of these person they'll go
through many people
yes and then what's behind those people
more people and what's behind those
people
more people and their children and their
families and cars and buildings and dogs
if she actually got this this is what
these people they don't care about well
actually though
at biden's inauguration that wouldn't
necessarily have been true because i was
there
but you know who wasn't there anybody
else right
the buildings are still you know the
buildings there and you know of course
all my co-workers thank god
uh we're you know everybody was safe but
they locked that thing down so much that
this was like a scene out of the hunger
games
where which i was saying even before
lady gaga got up uh with the actual
mockingjay on her on her uh
her address that there was
it didn't look like a mockingbird it
really looked like the mockingjay at 100
look at the mockingjay
you know the capital has won the rebels
have been defeated
a nation mourns yeah and
you would look out onto the national
lawn and it was empty
yeah there were nobody there there was
there was
one or two rows of like a few
you know dignitaries and then media and
then just
grass and then so they decided to put up
these little miniature american flags
and state flags and different things
to make it look like there was something
there because you know remember of
course this was a huge controversy
in in the early days of the trump
administration about how many people did
he have
right more than obama and sean spicer is
going through the numbers and all
but with biden there was nobody there
well they wouldn't let anybody go
right you couldn't get there right i had
to so my
studio was right there on constitution
ave so it was air for jan six i was
there for january 24 20th
um and that week the week of
inauguration for me to get through
it was complete military lockdown not
just
on the national mall or around the
capitol building like it is now
right now that was blocks and blocks
out you had to go through military
checkpoints i had to go through
tsa level secret service screening you
know the idea where you're they're going
through your bag
they're patting you down they're wanting
you i'd have my my media pass my media
credentials
and a list that i was on stating that i
was an essential worker this was the
building
and by the way if you were taking
pictures out there if you were up you
know
hey let me just record some of this
seeing as i am you're
in a media capacity that you were being
hounded off the street hey
i said you were going to that building
get to that building you know you know
i'm recording this for for my job this
is actually my work
you better get in there before or we're
going to revoke your credentials like
you didn't grant me my credentials right
you know but that's the level that it
went to even if you were just doing your
job out there trying to show people what
it was like
on inauguration day it's always just
following orders
from the the lowest scale of just kind
of jamming you up at a checkpoint to the
the atrocities
i hear stories about national guardsmen
in dc who are extremely demoralized by
what's going on but it's not like
they're gonna do anything well they're
not being forced to sleep in parking
lots
but but it's it's remarkable to me that
they could literally have
the as time magazine put cabal put them
in a parking garage with one bathroom
and one power outlet and no internet or
anything like that
and say sleep on the concrete and
they're like yes sir
it's it's i gotta admit the first thing
is it's actually admiral that admirable
that the guardsmen are willing to endure
this
in the name of doing right by our
country but it's shocking to me
that people would actually follow the
orders and and i don't i don't know how
to say it
but that's why probably why i will
actually i will say this that shows a
failure of leadership on the officer
court right
that when you're an officer and i was an
officer you
are a leader of your soldiers your
troops your sailors whichever it may be
uh guardians i think this is for space
force guardians
um so if i'm in a situation where i know
my
people are being asked to sleep in a
parking garage
you know i could understand going in
there on a movement and they said hey
let's be here for a little bit
you're asking me to sleep in there no no
no no no that's if i'm an o2 and i'm
gonna know three you know
you know um uh captain et cetera or
lower
you are going out there and i'm on the
phone with my major i'm on the phone
with my lieutenant colonel i'm saying
hey what's going on this is unacceptable
this is completely inappropriate is this
is this mission essential is it mission
essential for us to have to be in here
or not
you got to take care of your people and
it wasn't of course 26
000 people listened and did what they
were told a lot of the back blue people
are like
they're gonna not listen to all these
unconstitutional orders and i'm like you
have no
idea what you're talking about and you
have no sense of reality or
understanding of history
26 000 national guard troops over what
a threat alert where did the threat
alert come from was there any legitimacy
every time we pushed
obviously they couldn't give us any
information nothing but
this is another big thing here threats
it's going to cost the taxpayers a half
a billion dollars
to pay for all that security close to
500 million dollars of our tax dollars
is going for this security theater state
that
i know you're we have different
understanding of this but but it is
what it is right now it's a big security
state there's some troops standing
behind for other reasons and other
purposes we could talk about and
speculate about
that later but a half of a billion
dollars
spent on that i want a refund i want my
money back no no two thousand dollar
checks folks
i got a question i got a question for
you jack uh so the other day luke well
actually luke's made references to the
men who stare at goat several times
are you familiar with that that story
i've seen it like a million years ago
but yeah
so it was actually a non-fiction book i
think in 2004 about this like program
they did they tried doing psychological
psychology operations the jedi and stuff
like that it was called i think was
called like the stargate project
now in the movie when it opens they talk
about how this guy
came to actually be running this psychic
you know unit or whatever right
and they said that when he was deployed
to vietnam they that you know they land
and then one of his you know
one of the soldiers gets shot and he
sees this woman running through the
field and he says what are you doing
shoot and then all of the men start
shooting
and they all aimed high and in the movie
they say they found out that
fresh recruits don't want to shoot
anybody
and often either subconsciously or
intentionally miss
and so they're all shooting high and
missing this woman and then she shoots
the guy bill and he falls down
and then he has a vision of like you
know using
gen uh the gentle nature of their men as
their strength or something
but what was interesting to me was this
idea that fresh recruits don't want to
shoot somebody i'm wondering if that's
true or if you're well that actually is
true
and i'm surprised you don't know uh do
you know how the dod
was able to overcome that first person
human targets for first person shooters
wow human targets and first person
shooters were
some of the ways that they
psychologically came
out they used during training of vietnam
because
and this is back i remember this was
during the draft so a lot of people that
were forced to be there
they realized that you had to switch
from the
stationary you know ring targets that
you would have on the shooting range
to silhouettes to look make it look like
a person to condition you
to be able to pull that trigger to not
aim high as some of the original first
person shooters
actually came out of dod programs i
heard that before
and this was also done to be able to
start conditioning you that you know
it's it's okay this is normal this is
fine because
up until that point in human history it
had never been done before this idea
that
on a you know for kids right we let kids
play first person shooters
and that you're going to be conditioned
already from playing these games
that that's what you do and now now when
people go into the military
you're expecting it there's an
expectation that oh i'm going to deploy
and i get to shoot people and i get to
kick in doors and that's what joining
the military means
and so that's why you know you're asking
are they going to follow the laws you
like you understand right we've
conditioned people
to the understanding that joining the
military means i get to do these things
they broke them down and built them in a
way where they will always follow those
letters let me ask you if there was a
group
of trump supporters waving flags and
they were standing on an intersection
and a guardsmen or group were ordered to
fire on them immediately would they do
it
if they were told that there was an
imminent threat and to shoot those men
now stop them now
and to shoot i think you would see
people do it i think so too
yeah i think you have to if they if they
were if they were told it was an
imminent threat if they were told that
there was something about to happen that
that group is concealing
i think you would have to explain that
they wouldn't just do it
indiscriminately i
i've had a bunch of friends who uh told
me that they never thought it was
possible like some conservative friends
i've had a long time you know
from years ago back in chicago would say
things like dude after kent state and
things like that
that you're never going to see this kind
of martial law ridiculous thing
but then i actually went and stayed on a
couple of military bases i briefly lived
on fort carson in colorado just outside
of springs and i also lived just outside
of fort eustis in newport news
and i actually asked some of the active
duty personnel and they said
they're like they're not machines
they're like dude it's a simple
simplistic question like if i was
ordered to shoot an american would i do
it it's like that's not how it goes down
what goes down is someone says we've got
intelligence of a potential terroristic
threat
and then there's someone you know coming
towards you and they say that's him
that's him
take him down now what are you going to
do be like no thanks
dude no you're going to be like i will
follow the orders a civilian in a car
and killed him and then the mass media
started saying it was a
potential threat they were an imminent
threat people would not
some people would freak out there would
be like waco there would be like
movements of protest
but it would normalize it and what this
time magazine thing is if people don't
stand up to this it's gonna normalize it
for the next election
and then it's setting a precedent well
the psychological dehumanizing programs
are
already pretty much existent and when
you look at some of the language when
you look at how
weaponized it is when you look how
sensational it is it's it's pushing
people
to that this is why you know i had a
t-shirt with the mainstream media poking
a stick to to do a conflict yeah i can't
say even the full phrase
yeah yeah the shirt got centered i
brought it back up his shirt's still up
right now
uh but but this is happening and i think
this is akin to what we're seeing in
in time akin to what we're seeing in
msnbc and what we're going to be seeing
and some people are pointing to the fact
that these news organizations are losing
ratings they're losing viewership
you know that could be maybe you know an
understanding partially of it but i
think there's something bigger deep
suckers they've been seeing this
especially with the longer bigger
connections that a lot of these media
organizations have with intelligence
organizations
that work hand in hand together pushing
out this propaganda on the front line
sometimes even intelligence agencies
writing entire articles
and just having journalists put their
name behind it that happens in american
media in international media and this is
something we need to worry about because
those talking points those words
set an agenda set a perception
that puts out a scenario that is
unfolding right in front of us and it's
a nasty scenario that we're seeing right
now
and something that we were just saying
before uh shows like
24 and sleeper cell and homeland that
all
came out in sort of that that three to
four year period
after 9 11 getting you to think that oh
your your neighbor
is a radical that was something that's
actually this has all been sort of a red
pill for me to go back and say wait a
minute
i used to watch that show i used to love
jack bauer right saving the country ctu
right he's the good guy but wait was
that
conditioning to me of course did you
ever watch law and order svu no
you say i'm i'm i'm a fan of a law and
order series and
law order svu with stabler and uh
like what's the other lady's name i
don't know mr hargitay
but the character couldn't tell yeah why
i can't forget i i used to actually
enjoy watching uh all the law order
stuff criminal intent was really good
because they had uh uh
vincent d'onofrio on it so he's awesome
yeah that was great
the reason i didn't like the reason svu
wasn't my favorite uh
is because stabler would routinely
violate people's constitutional rights
brutally beat them
and it was like a part of his character
that he would get the wrong person
he would scream in their faces and then
it would like sort of
give him pause when he realized what he
did and i'm like why am i supposed to
root for this cop who's
like i understand it's svu okay that's
like a
uh kind of the questions in that show
are gruesome and brutal
but like you have a cop who's literally
you know there there's like an episode
where he beats up a guy and it turns out
the guy wasn't
the suspect but he was just so enraged
by the crime i'm like
am i we're supposed to root for these
guys well there's a reason the cia
tweets out support of black panther and
why the pentagon
spends hundreds of millions of dollars
especially american taxpayer dollars in
rewriting scripts for major movies and
tv shows all throughout the united
states we have to understand there's a
bigger agenda throughout the subliminal
messaging
that a lot of times we don't pick up we
don't notice we're not on alerts to look
out for
you know the messaging behind
entertainment because we put our guard
down we think we're just being
entertained
when in reality people are being
programmed to believe a certain
thing that benefits of course the ruling
class right and you're starting now to
see this
in media where the last season of
punisher right it was
all about domestic extremists and the
last season of bosch
on amazon prime was all about quote
unquote sovereign citizens
though i will give them credit because
it actually ended up being that the fbi
was smearing the sovereign citizens
at the end sorry spoiler for everybody
there um but
you know going back and thinking about
24 like they're probably going to get
keiver sutherland back and they'll do a
reboot of it
and it'll all be based on you know
people with gadsden flag
and don't tread on me and oh he's got a
bad you know chloe's on the
on the the laptop going he's got the
flag up that says the second protects
the first that's it
all right we're calling the strike
calling the strike tim go go go
you know here you want me have you guys
seen the music video for
um uh that taylor swift song
what's it called uh what do you need to
shut up or something yeah what i'm
talking about calm down
you need to calm down i've watched all
of taylor swift's music videos
religiously
she has this song called you need to
calm down and at first
it sounds like she's singing about
cancel culture about how people are on
twitter just like snapping at her it's
like dude you need to calm down
and i'm like oh okay like legit like
yeah i remember that when i first
come to it all calm down the whole
second verse is a caricature
of conservatives as if they're like as
if the millennial conservative is
comparable to
the 90s conservative and so she's then
singing about like lgbt rights and how
it's like a bunch of people who are like
hillbillies waving signs
you know about you know not spelled yeah
misspelled signs opposing
lgbt rights and it's like that video was
probably created by someone by some gen
xer who's in their 50s and that's their
perception of the conservatives
and so then taylor swift makes this for
12 year olds or 14 year olds or whatever
who now will have that perception of
conservatives without ever
have ever having talked to one and so
this is part of the phenomenon where we
can see the left doesn't know anything
about the right
it was like that smith did that movie
red state which is exactly like that
yeah they were people have their i think
it was their car broke down and they
were stuck in the back woods and it was
all these sort of like ur
hillbilly type but hold on
one second one second did you see that
movie what's it called where the woman
the the the liberals kidnapped the trump
supporters the hunt the hunt yeah that
movie
is really good it's so really really
shocked
i you know the act i started i actually
started to watch it because i'll i'll
watch lockheed movies you know b
movies here and there the script just
killed it for me it's
so over the top for those that aren't
familiar this is a very controversial
film
where the trailer shows liberals
kidnapping trump supporters and then
hunting them for sports
you didn't see the ending i didn't see
the ending the ending like basically
makes you hate everybody and it's pretty
good don't bring it i don't want to ruin
it
but i was laughing the whole time
running for me after i'm not going to
watch it yeah
yeah no no the the ending makes you
laugh i saw like when they were on the
private jet
the movie the movie's non-partisan it's
not in support of the left or the right
it's making fun of the whole thing and i
respect it for it but you were saying
let's we'll get more stuff
where is this all leading to i mean this
is leading to literally bad movies
npr also calling for terrorist
counter insurgency tactics to be used in
the united states and when you look
at those larger calls msnbc time
magazine npr
it it's it's building up it's crescent
on the way here
rand corporation right the rand
corporation this was the iraq war
organization they created the war on
terror they're widely credited for
creating it
headline on their their com their
commentary today domestic violent
extremists will be harder to combat than
homegrown jihadists
and also these are failed individuals
who who absolutely
did a horrible job at what they were
supposed to do they were supposed to
fight terrorism but they built a whole
bunch of terrorists
all throughout the middle east
especially helping resurrect
you know this new creature called isis
that was directly because of their
government decisions but also
when we look at that type of garbage
it's either just
utter intelligence agency propaganda
pushed on you
or just utter demoralizing crap like
today
uh cardi b released a new music video
and it's called up
and kids who are going to be looking for
that disney movie are going to be
traumatized
uh and it is i mean some of the lyrics
we can't even say here i would love to
do a ben shapiro impression and just
talk about some of the
the lyrics here uh but it's number one
it's trending you go to trending on
youtube right now you get
that and you'll be shocked to see that's
okay that's promoted that's given to
everyone's news feed
that came up on my newsfeed and i don't
care about nicki minaj i don't watch
nicki minaj
sorry cardi b but but that's that's
thrown out
to me in in and of course actually i
can't even say that because so i have a
two-year-old right and sometimes
when he'll go on youtube um or or my you
know we have my parents in love with
live with us and they'll put on youtube
but sometimes it'll be logged in on my
account so
maybe i'm watching teamcast irl or
watching something in the news
but then they won't switch it to kid
mode so they'll put on a kids show
but it the autoplay will load something
like that that's on you guys you know i
know but yeah again
right you know they're not they're just
thinking hey let's put on something for
the kid
but then it'll it'll load something from
the news or to load something from
music now personally mostly i listen to
like you know either
cyber wave or like lo-fi when i'm when
i'm actually writing
but i think about that a lot more now as
to
what he he's going to get he can already
type by the way he's two years old he
can type
right he can actually do he can't even
write but he can type so he's going to
be putting
words together pretty soon here so what
happens when
he gets a computer and he's going on
youtube
and or whatever it is you know whatever
platform where he goes and then
algorithm starts feeding stuff in and
now i'm starting to have those thoughts
this is tough um a lot of the big tech
ceos bar their children from having cell
phones because they know
you can't just give a child access to
the summation of human knowledge
and depravity at the same time are you
going to home school
we're we're currently thinking about
what what we want to do i mean i'm
catholic
so there are you need to homeschool
there's a lot of well there's a lot of
options right there's cat there's
catholic schools there's catholic co-ops
like pods that they have a different
power series
yeah there's different there's different
uh i think i said montessori monasteries
yeah
exactly yeah no but or or homeschool you
know we're
we're currently thinking about what we
want to do what makes sense for us
because when he goes to kindergarten
some kids can have an iphone with no no
no like
locks on it well it's just gonna unless
it's the school bands at all but even
then they probably got one
well that's that's the thing though is
what kind of school you know what's
their you know what's their standard on
that do they
rule about that i think i was lucky
because i went from kindergarten to the
end of
fifth grade at catholic school okay
which was very uptight
and strict and then sixth seventh and
eighth was
public grade school which was a bunch of
kids with no rules
in gangs getting drunk and smoking pot
and so
that mixture of like realities i think
was really
good for me you got to see both sides of
the coin yeah and and i started with the
the more strict you know like the kids
at this school would cry
if they forgot their homework like it
was really everyone really ties you'd
wear your tie
every time you got a misconception kids
would cry yeah i remember that yeah you
go to public school and the kids would
be like the
the teacher would be like can you turn
your homework in i didn't do it well
you're gonna get a zero
and okay then walk away yeah i yeah i
had a huge
huge uh a big difference when i came
from poland poland it was
you know everything was it was very nice
and people were always cordial to you
people are always talking to you
respectful of you too a public new york
city school where you would fight
someone and the teachers would cheer on
i'm not even joking
i'm not even exaggerating like they were
there's just fights and teachers
just watch and place bets and like who's
going to win michael mallis has a great
line about that we're not great but it's
the way he always says quips where he
says you know public schools might be
the one place where you actually face
violence yeah
that's true yeah yeah they're little
prisons that's what that's what he says
yeah so i have a question for you guys
um should we be serious or
snarky in the next segment the next
story we we can jump to we have one
that's like really serious
well you can't say that without yeah oh
you're you're you're picking with
something
we've got we've got a story that's silly
and nonsensical and funny and then we've
got one that's serious and alarming no i
say go to serious and then get to silly
well we were pretty serious all right so
we have something we
did we did we could go to snarky and
then go serious again i don't want to go
back
i like all right i'll just tell you i'll
let me just ask you would you prefer to
talk about
bank of america is giving away people's
private information yes to work with the
feds
scary stuff well that kind of ties into
what we're already saying right right so
that's why i was like we could just
that's a good
easy segue there we could talk about
david hogg starting a pillow company
yeah what's up with that i've heard some
interesting developments around that i
have
i i i i i better throw out that i said
what are they gonna call it cry pillow
[Laughter]
all right let's talk about bank of
america well i think we got the joke out
of david hogg starting that's awesome
yeah something briefly on
uh the pillow thing they say i guess
they want to put my pillow out of
business
they're not going to that my pillow
advertises on fox news
david hogg is just not like doing things
to get someone else
is like vote for biden so that you can
screw trump make a pillow company so you
can put that one out of bed that's not
how reality he does understand by the
way that there are al
other pillow companies already right
every other pillow company is trying to
put my pillow out of business that's how
business works right
there's a problem with like socialists
don't understand how business works that
yes there are lots of pillow companies
that compete with mike lindell that's
that's not how he work his you are not
going to get
his audience because mike lindell's
audience buys his pillows
for number one by the way i actually
have my pillow i like it
really good yeah it's a like that's what
i you know i wish i had more than one
i can't stand how the left lies about
the pillow because they don't like him
they're like it's awful oh like there
was one article where like i bought the
pillow and it was the worst thing ever
and this one was like my boy this female
writer is like my boyfriend said what is
this trash and why did you buy it
it's like i was at walmart and i saw the
my pillow thing and i laughed and i was
like i throw it in the throat in the you
know in the cart
and then i got it back and i was like
well first of all i would recommend you
need more than one pillow
but obviously two pillows two regular
pillows
um it's okay but a regular pillow and a
my pillow it's actually
really that's actually what i do yeah
that's actually what i do two pillows
one sack
like do you put both your pillows in one
pillowcase no
two pillows one sack that's where it's
at oh it's but the
my the here we are doing a my pillow is
it for my knees look i
i think that's what all this is
criticizing he just wants us to sell his
pillows for you you can criticize the
guy i don't care i i'm i'm not gonna
stand for the guy but it's a pillow dude
and
it's annoying to me that the culture war
extends to like oh
i hate that movie because it was this or
that because it had
the wrong you know race of character in
it or something like
whatever who cares was the movie or was
the movie bad that's why they went after
um oh what was the film
where they were where it was actually
the point of the film
was the fact that it was reincarnation
and
i thought you're gonna bring up tropic
thunder and robert downey jr thunder no
not tropic thunder because i love that
movie but it was it was reincarnation
but it was all the same actors and so
they wanted to
it was tom hanks uh uh atlas uh
thank you i would say i saw that like
nine times in the theaters i love that
film
i think that was that's one of the
movies where number one it's better than
the books actually read the book as well
but the whole point of it was that
it was talking about how humans have
shared experiences and how
something that affects one person in one
time can affect another person that you
might never even meet in the future
that was the whole point that they had
the same actors going through
and playing but then they trashed the
movie it ended up not doing well because
the rotten tomatoes score wasn't great
because they were using the same actors
and they would have you know a
european actor played an asian character
oh that's right and they were going over
there and they were going the other way
around where
an asian actor was playing a european
character but it wasn't the point
my favorite thing was when i worked for
fusion which was the abc intervention
univision joint venture and ghost in the
shell the movie was coming out right
with scarlett johansson's playing uh
motoko uh kasanagi or kusanagi right and
she said japanese
but you're are you from you're familiar
with ghost in the shell yeah
for those that are not familiar in the
sci-fi world of ghost in the shell but
she's a robot
exactly your soul your ghost could be
transferred to a prosthetic body
so one of the themes is transhumanism
that you
that you're literally this this woman
was born asian
and then when she was hit by a car or
something they transferred her
consciousness into a prosthetic body
which was now
ethnically ambiguous or in the movie
played by scarlett johansson
so they were so at fusion they all
started going like oh this is good we
can write about this this is going to be
so
oh man how could they do that and i was
in there and i'm like oh actually it's
the theme of like
the show that you can transcend bodies
and be whoever you want it's actually
fairly pro like you know it's kind of
similar to altered cards
it's it's right it's actually pro social
justice racial
yeah and they were like no no they're
getting a white actress to play a
japanese woman i'm like she's a robot
he's a prosthetic body her ghost is is
in the shadow
i mean let's just need you much yeah
take it to jumanji hey you brought up
tropica thunder i want to point out
robert downey jr not in blackface in in
tropic thunder who's the last guy to get
away with it
that blackface is a specific artist
never again he was the last one
there's a specific art form called
blackface where you have a circular
uh area of black on your face it's not
when you're workplace your entire
skin and body that's not black yeah and
they wore white hand gloves
right it's a specific art form called
blackface this other stuff is not black
but now it's become that well it's not
like this is the big thing in the new um
and i was
saying earlier that i'm reading the
ready player two in which is the sequel
to ready player one
where in the new version of the uh the
oasis which is this
massive virtual reality network that
everyone is using in the future
they've now come up with a new update
for it where instead of just logging in
no you don't log in it's basically
neurolink plus virtual reality
so that the new thing it straight up
chip in your brain
and that and that every experience you
have in virtual reality it's
fully sensuous all all of your senses
are actually ended in this
but you can also record
things in real life and then this
becomes a popular thing to do
where you can go onto so sims are
recordings of things in the simulation
but recs
are recordings of other people's
experiences that you can experience
you can experience and so if you want to
get high on heroin
that which is actually something that
the main character he ends up doing
because it turns out his mother died of
a heroin overdose
so he never did heroin but he started to
become interested
what what is it like when i'm on heroin
why did my mother
go and do this why did she choose this
life over living with me and it's
this whole huge character thing so he
ends up going and doing it and having
that experience but without any of the
physiological
uh restrictions on it so instead of
doing snarky or
crazy i think we did a little bit of
both we actually let's do let's do
somewhat serious but more interesting we
have this from entrepreneur.com
neural link could begin testing human
brain implants
this year says elon musk implants
grafted into the brain and spinal cord
seek to be able to correct paralysis and
cure alzheimer's no i'll just i'm going
to say this
dude the idea that we could neurolink
and repair the nerve damage from
someone's spine
and like give them the ability to walk
coolest thing i've ever heard
but you want to know what is also very
cool not as cool as helping those who
are paralyzed but
up there elon musk says nora link has
wired up a monkey to play video
games using its mind similar yeah
did he say which game it was though
that's what i want to know i'm hoping it
was mario brothers
probably minecraft brothers mario
brothers like the original
not mario kart they're not
and you get to punch bricks you're
fighting that's the one where you punch
bricks
super mario super mario brothers right
the first one's called mario brothers
right i'm talking about you're actually
fighting luigi yes
yeah yeah you're reversing each other
i'm talking about on the side
the monkey's playing a game where you
get a dude to jump on turtles and crush
them to death and
punch bricks that game is brutal you
can't punch bricks in super mario
brothers yes you can you headbutt
that's not true the animation is mario
jumping and raising it
oh you're right and punching the board
it is punch
yes when he jumps his fists go punches
the brick nerd
so it's that's canon is he's punching
why do you think they give him punches
in later games i wonder how many people
get that wrong on like who wants to be a
millionaire oh for sure he's not bashing
his head people think he has he built it
people also
also think he's spitting fireballs his
hand goes up
no no i know he's throwing farts he's
definitely throwing fire so in in later
games you can
butt stomp and punch bricks straight up
like in in the later marios he actually
can punch
but in the original he runs and jumps
it's it's brutal game you're running
around as a dude
punching bricks getting high on
mushrooms punching bricks
stomping turtles okay game's crazy
anyway anyway
she's talking about the social
conditioning of video games
what is mario kart what's mario kart
what's the subliminal messaging
yeah sure when you when you're enlisting
they're like what video game you played
the most
and then they have like a unit of guys
in like call of duty and they're like
training for combat
and then they have people who said super
mario brothers and they're running
around kicking turtles and
doing mushrooms but okay anyway the news
the mushrooms are a telltale
the monkey thing you take a lot of them
and you take the mushroom and you grow
well it's a reference to alice in
wonderland and then going down the
right yeah a lot of people don't know
that so the mushrooms reference to alice
in wonderland i'm gonna need
elon musk teased that neural link could
begin implanting computer chips later
this year
quote number link is working very hard
to ensure implant safety and is in close
communication with the fda if things go
well
we may be able to do initial human
trials later this year
the statement came in response to a
comment from a user who asked him to
participate in human testing or who
asked
yes i was in a car accident 20 years ago
and since then i've been paralyzed from
the shoulders
i am always available for clinical
studies at nora link wrote
hamoon kamai on the social network dude
legit hook them up
days before musk assured that neuralink
already has a laboratory monkey with a
chip implanted in its skull
you can play video games with your mind
said the owner of spacex
the short term goal of neural the
nurling project is to solve brain and
spinal injuries
while in the long term it would seek
human ai
symbiosis i'm not entirely sure what
video game they're playing
they say it's not an unhappy monkey he
said during a talk on clubhouse
a new social media we know that is you
can't even see where the neural implant
was put in
except that he's got a slight a slight
like dark mohawk
the uh the billionaire who spoke about
space travel colonies etc
said he was playing mind they were
playing mind pong with each other
that would be pretty cool what's up this
is pong pong yeah that's what i wanted
i wanted to figure out wow that means
that's rudimentary dude i'm playing mind
pong with you right now
what if you can control control the
mouse on your computer click things open
things pull up videos
just by thinking it like you won't even
need a mouse pointer you'll just know
you'll just point you just click ever
you'll be clicking
it with your thoughts so i have uh i'm
ready for ai to just take over let's
just guys
maybe they already take it take the keys
you know we we already have shadowy
cabals that are running our country
so just give it to you let's just hand
it over skynet the t1 thousands let's do
it what if it happened a long time ago
what if we already yeah we're already in
there well that's also the simulation
theory is uh so would you are you going
to get the neural link jack
plug me in baby let's do it i'll plug me
right in no i wouldn't do no way no no
i don't know it's unless if i was if i
was in that situation
where god forbid and you know my wife
always hates when i talk about hype
that's just don't say that don't say
that
you know yeah knock on wood right it's
eastern europe but yeah exactly exactly
he doesn't want me to do that ever but
sweetheart if you're listening it's for
entertainment
were i in that situation where i was
paralyzed
having been in a car accident when you
hear those situations
yeah i would definitely i would totally
sign up to be one of the tests i would
absolutely do that just push your wife
it's like saying if you were cold would
you put on a jacket
i mean it's so obvious don't say that i
don't want to be cold you wouldn't ever
be cold i've never again i don't mean
interruption i know but no you're
exactly right that's what
that's where i'm coming from but she's
like don't even say it don't even say it
but think about right now they're at the
level of pong
right well we were we were at pong
levels what 40 years ago
50 50 what was it what what 1970s 70s
yeah i think it was seven yeah so
about 40 or so years ago we had pong
come out now we have virtual reality you
know
skyrim and in you know 120 frames or
whatever you got a really good computer
and you can actually go into vr worlds
and draw the bow and the graphics are
way better
not like skyrim has the best graphics in
the world i'll be honest but uh
video games have gone a long way where
is neural link video game technology
going to be in 40 or 50 years
are you going to be able to plug in and
then experience
like you were mentioning with the rex
well that's ready player one and two
that's the whole
world is and they they actually get into
the morality of it how
for people that might be low income for
people in poverty
it's actually this is the main character
he grows up living in these like uh
trailer park in the midwest
that for him it's an escape from the
enwi of his
his daily existence that he's i know
right
right there that's one of the sap words
that he's able to get into and now
but in in this world you're you know
you're the star of your own universe
you can go visit castles and nights and
everything whereas you're living in the
slums
let's be real like you know i i run this
show
i've got a bunch of channels called tim
cast bunch of followers and awesome
people who watch
it's true i would still much love to be
i still play skyrim i just started i
started a new skyrim
run down on some mods i'd i'd love to
plug in and just go to a magical world
and be some random dude throwing
fireballs at dragons man
that'd be fun we're gonna get advanced
enough where you can be game you can be
playing skyrim right now and still
having this kind of one eye
is like spazzing you probably have like
17 videos
like 70 video games going at once and as
you're having a conversation
yeah it's going to allow us to okay
assuming you're fine and no nothing bad
happens all good
because you're probably gonna be fine um
will you get the neural link if
it seems to work and five years go by
and people start getting it and they get
like super human intelligence and
um interoperability yeah seemingly
i just no i i because when i hear
stories about time mag
and when i hear stories about the the
money powers work together to ensure the
proper outcome
i just don't i think of all the ways
that this could be abused i think of
all the viruses that right not just from
you know the elite quote unquote but
from you know just any bad actors that
want to get involved with this thing or
get into this thing
you know could you imagine getting brain
hacked like it's a thing
with your brain hacking though well they
have to implant the animals too but you
probably could
they can remote control cockroaches you
see that ew yeah so
they they uh they can remote they put
can put a thing on a cockroach that
affects its
sensory can you do a lot of them at once
because i can think about a lot of
people i'd like to send
they can remote they can remote control
humans they did it
they did a test where they were able to
shift the sense of balance through
equilibrium
so what happens is you have to go in a
certain direction so you feel like
you're falling
right and so you start moving to try and
try to compensate yep and they're
like they're laughing and like you put
on a headset or something dude it
crazy stuff is on the horizon man back
in 2011
i me me and some friends bought a
consumer grade
it's called an extra
electroencephalogram or an eeg i think
it's called
as you do a headband as one does yes
it's a headband and it's got a thing
that goes in your head and it measures
hospitals brain waves yeah right and so
what this
is this is crazy we we uh opened up a
program
that can detect the brain waves and then
we me and my friend we put it on
and you try to control the wave to make
it go up and make it go down
and it's like random and we couldn't do
it and i was like i don't believe this
is legit i can't believe it works
we gave it to his sister and she was
like so you want me to make it go up and
it went
straight up and we were like whoa when
she goes and now make it go down and we
went down and we were like
whoa how do you do that and she was like
i just thought
to make it happen like and it took her
no time at all to figure it out
what we wanted to do was make a a mind
mind-controlled drone
but because of the limitations of the
eeg we had it only had two
two axis uh accident two axes axes yeah
axes
axes so we could make it rotate and go
up and down and i was like that's all we
need
the problem if i put it on i could not
control it because my brain is like i
don't understand this
it would be like if you've never gone
skateboarding you stand on a skateboard
you're like you're gonna fall
so if we could actually get to the point
the technology is still easily available
if not it's been dramatically
upgraded in the past 10 years but we we
theoretically had the tech because all
you had to do was write a simple code
to synchronize their existing consumer
technology showing the wave
going up and down with the function of
increasing and decreasing power to the
drones rotors
and that was not through an implant you
just had to put it on like a headband
and you could make that happen and then
control a drone we we
you you could theoretically think like
the the plan was this
it's all possible you would think to go
up or down it could go up and down and
then you would think to spin and it
would spin in one direction
so then you could like aim it and then
come down and then go up and then rotate
moving your body around like you think
that your hands
like that's how we move our bodies it's
a thought process right the weird thing
is though
we can feel ourselves when we move stuff
and when you grab something you can feel
its interaction with your muscles
like let's say you're holding a bat or a
sword it feels like an extension of you
because it
it all of the senses in your arm it's
shifting the weight it's putting
pressure on this point of this muscle
this muscle's tightening
and you can feel the weight and control
it and in fact humans do this with cars
there was i was reading that's that's
muscle memory where you're talking about
that that
once you once you've done it enough
times you don't think about it but it's
what i'm trying to say is that some
there's there's something different
where humans when they use tools
it becomes an extension of their body in
the mind the mind actually says i
understand this is here and how long it
is
the same thing is true with cars that's
why you i don't know if this is true for
everybody but i was reading
when you're driving a car you have no
problem drinking when you're a passenger
in a car
you're like spilling and it's like
hitting you because you don't know
what's gonna happen you're
you have no control of the tool same
with hitting the brakes and stuff right
now think about that it's like a car
sick when you're a passenger or not
you're driving
the one of the challenges of controlling
a drone with your mind
is that you can't feel anything about it
it's all visual
so you're looking at it and in order to
make it do the right thing
you have to see it do it you don't feel
it like i can
feel myself pick something up i don't
need to see it my brain instantly
understands and it knows the weight
knows balance everything
the drone i have no idea i could not be
looking at i had no idea what's going on
so it's it's it's all it's it's much
more difficult
uh i digress however the neural link
technology
is is i think a lot of people look at
that and
assume we have to have implants in order
to have this kind of tech
no we could drive a car with a headband
you
you theoretically get to a point where
we have multiple nodes and you just put
a
hat on or a tattoo well i'm saying
nothing implantable
yeah i'm saying literally like a
wearable and then it just can you know a
wearable on your head
a tattoo is permanent i'm talking about
a tattoo it doesn't have to be permanent
but i'm i'm saying you would you
wouldn't need that you'd get in your car
you'd sit down
and then there would just be a thing you
just put it on your head and then
you go you drive why get the neural link
and and it would give you the sensory
perception of the drone like it would be
able to feed into your brain what the
drone's experiencing
these so far are read-only it's reading
activity coming out of your brain not
putting anything into it
that's what the the the issue with uh
nora link is
it's it's what do they say it's
read-only yeah as far as i know like
when i saw the pig demonstration it was
read only and the monkey playing pong is
read only like
basically your brain has no sensations
of its own right you can't actually feel
it that's what it would you don't need
to do
you anesthetize when you're doing
brainstorming for for the actual brain
organ itself in order to get to the
point where we would be at risk
well you could be at risk for in a lot
of ways with an implant but in order to
get to the point where you could have
like
a video game in your mind you
experienced through newer link we would
need
right writable technology i'm not sure
that's going to be possible
because everyone's brain is different
it's not the same code it's a very very
similar code but
it's they're all unique structures that
are that's actually that's
this we mentioned that's a huge thing in
ready player two where um the company
has to sign oh
make you sign all sorts of waivers
before you get in and there's a 12 hour
time limit
but then also that apparently there's a
lot of people that hooked up to it that
jacked in
and they just their synapses got
completely overloaded
and so they've had to try it very
carefully to like make the companies
like make
their bodies go away right uh totally
spasmodic
um you know seizures catatonic don't
ruin the movie
is it out it's not it's not a movie it's
a book no this is the sequel to
uh ready player one yeah ready player
one was a book they made a movie and now
there's a sequel ready to play ready
play and so and it's
really really good because it gets into
all this and but they you know did
everything they could to try to make it
go away
and they canceled all the recordings of
it and you know
they can bribe every politician so you
know there's no worry about the laws or
regulations because they know everything
about you already because everyone who
signed in or your family members are
signed in you know you have
blackmail on everybody can you could you
imagine there's like uh you know elon
musk has this factory or this like
warehouse laboratory
and then like deep in like level six sub
basement there's people like strapped in
against their will with like
neural neural link in their brains
they're happy no they're totally happy
no no no no no no no they're they're
it's like you have to see batman the
animated series where the people are
scared but smiling because of the jokers
again yes
that's what it's like they're like it's
like this weird creepy face
just walks up is everyone enjoying the
game everyone's happy
you're enjoying how is your how is your
ride in the tesla roadster is it going
well and you're like
the windows are impenetrable yeah
i'm uh what about what about you tim how
are you feeling about the getting the
neural link these days
you you want the headband that's what
you want well the headband's nice for
controlling things or you're free to be
a beanie yeah
the the neural beanie the problem the
the i would say right now new merch
available timcast.com
i'm not i'm not immediately averse to
neural link lydia write that down i will
say however
we have to come a long way to ensure
safety on newer links so it's not going
to happen in 10 years
you know elon musk might do trials on it
now the first thing we'll end up seeing
is
if he can actually transmit uh
information just it doesn't have to be a
specific code
it just has to be able to transfer
information between nerves he can repair
people who have paralysis and then what
happens is
uh when the nerves damaged you no longer
can move right
even repairing it you have to relearn
because your brain's trying to figure
out that pathway to communicate with
with that part of the body
so even if elon creates something that
can create a link between
you know neurons then people will have
to relearn how to walk that's gonna be
the first thing we see
before there's anything else that'll be
interesting partly because
how will you connect to it to control it
will it be an internal device with no
connectivity just a simple
you know powered by the brain electrical
impulses and that's it or will it have
to have a battery in it
will it have a bluetooth connection
because we have seen in the past decade
pete they're they're i think i'm not
sure if it happened to anybody but i
think someone may have been assassinated
because they had uh
a pacemaker would you like bluetooth or
something right yeah
yeah there's like stories of people who
have
internal electronics either like an
electronic pancreas system
or a pacemaker and people can hack into
it using its
like because i think i think i was
reading a story about pacemakers
having a signal so that doctors can
connect and then collect information and
see how things are going
someone could break into that and then
change that you know that system and
then kill you
so what would happen if there's anything
i know about humanity
is that there is no system
that anyone can design that someone else
will not figure out how to reverse
engineer
but this is the thing tim keeps bringing
up we're not smart enough to do this but
we're also forgetting that you know
human beings are building concepts like
artificial intelligence and quantum
computing that are way smarter that are
way more proficient they could calculate
problems
way faster than a human being could
figure out and could be way more
intelligent than the average human being
could be and they could figure it out
and they could give us
just new kind of technology or twist it
or use it in some kind of way for
the artificial intelligence personal
benefit so that's also another spectrum
here that we would be foolish enough to
think about since of course there is an
artificial intelligence race happening
right now
with amazon with facebook with elon musk
with vladimir putin with china
all racing for what people are calling
the next big
nuclear weapon that of course will be
weaponized will be used for the personal
benefit of some individuals but
with an intelligence that's smarter than
us
that's that's dangerous territory
because look at what we do to things
that are less intelligent than us
well this is what gets into right this
gets into the singularity right
when machines overcome and this is every
sci-fi book
novel etc where eventually the machines
decide we don't need you with the
with the i will say the notable
exception of her where the ais just
leave
that was a such a creepy movie yeah i
remember watching dude battlestar
galactica
sad man like like just the just the the
intro episode where
you have these planets all these
different planet colonies
and you could live on a bunch of
different planets and then the the
cylons just come and like
wipe out the entire civilization it's
like that's so brutal man
because you took our birthright from us
yeah
that's history that that's when you look
at history it's
you know the the burning of uh
alexandria the the describer
the destruction of so much knowledge has
been wasted away and
so much and some of it has been
protected and we should always protect
it at all costs
yeah this um that or that i don't know
what the word is perpetuity of uh
humans to seek out and destroy other
life forms like to actually look for
them and find them to destroy them is
like
that's real that's part of the humanity
so i would imagine that any programs we
build are gonna
are gonna also be able to do that right
because again the
this is the garbage and gorgeous right
any ai will initially come from
a human right so any any of our own
biases
and idiosyncrasies and flaws are all
going to be built into it
yeah and there's no way around with that
being said we should throw it to the
super chat so if you haven't already
leave a super chat but like subscribe to
the notification bell and head over to
timcast.com become a member for
exclusive
members only content some people have
asked is there going to be sponsors or
ads or anything
no members only content has no ads no
sponsors it is straight clean
unfiltered uncensored a lot of cussing
and that is
for you guys we're not going to do any
promo stuff it'll always just be clean
and and ready to go
that's at timcast.com we got a cool uh
segment up about
new technology and maybe a major
breakthrough and we'll we will probably
have another bonus segment coming up
later
i'm not entirely sure but uh stick
around and we'll see what happens but
let's take some of these super chats
we got mickey the fourth saying
yesterday i was a guest on a channel
called
radical liberation to talk about what
happened in chech
chechiya yeah chechnya well there's no n
yeah it says chechia maybe chechnya
after communism
i think it is vital to understand the
lasting effects and what
what it is that comes after give it a
watch and share if you can thanks guys
cool
maybe it's a place i'm not familiar with
bringer of d says canada officially
declares proud voice a terror
organization
finance minister now considering massive
tax hikes to cover 10 million
10 million payments to individual
members wait what
ha to individual members of of the
ministry or the proud boys
oh he says jk oh i get it there's a joke
all right
jose diaz says tim how long until the
u.s starts looking like so many
dystopian movies
because so far to me it's looking like v
for vendetta without v
how long until what do you mean go back
a year
like we've been locked down for a year
people are walking around terrified of
this pandemic
now they're wearing two masks well it's
actually judge wears two masks i would
say
even beyond v for vendetta i think it's
more like dark city
if people remember that one where dark
city was this is sort of the original
matrix
where your history your memories
are rewritten every night and every
night at one point i think it's at
midnight everybody falls asleep
and then the you know the the ancients
run out
rewire your memories reform the city
they actually change the streets you
could be rich
one day and then you wake up and you're
like you know in a bathtub of like a
slum
or you're in the bathtub you're at the
kitchen table
in you know a beater and you're yelling
over some some cheap dinner but then you
wake up and you're in a mansion right
but the idea also is that they've
plugged into your mind
all the memories that would give you up
until that point and so there's this one
scene of the movie where the main
character is trying to figure out
when's the last do you remember the last
time you had a steak yeah
but when's the last time you actually
had it can you remember the specific
time and the date that's what we're
getting to with a lot of these lockdowns
it's like can you remember what life was
like
prior to but when did they start what
was the day that it started what was the
actual time when was the last time you
did this when was the last time you did
that two weeks
right two weeks right two weeks or just
no it'll be done in two weeks it'll be
done
i mean to be completely honest we live
in the middle of nowhere so once you get
away from the city
it's meaningful yeah actually out here
it's probably not as bad but in i've
been in dc the entire time
and it's i'm having trouble remembering
when the last time i walked down the
street
like with my family on a regular
unmasked
dc day was i was uh i was super excited
because today i was able to hit
i think it's a six inch target from 100
yards with my account with my
compound bow it took me like 30 tries
though
so it's not like i'm good it was just a
really great feeling where i was
this tiny six-inch target from like 100
yards and i was shooting and missing and
missing
and it was the last arrow and it was
funny because the air was like
kind of broken so i actually missed and
the arrow still ended up hitting it but
i'll take it
so anyway i don't know
i don't know i don't know testing that
it hit the target sure it did by
accident but
the arrow hit the target but did tim hit
the target yeah yes
anyway the point is i go out in the yard
no mask
trees everywhere right there's birds
making normal weird noises there's one
bird that sings that muse song from from
uh
it's called pressure yeah well they're
everywhere i don't know what the birds
called
but there's a bird that's that like it's
it's song sounds those are drones
so we're just like
and it sounds like a person yelling yes
and so i'm going out with wilhelm with
with the bow
and i'm like getting ready and then i
hear a ah and i'm like
somebody there i'm i'm shooting air do
you need aids
i'm like because it's middle of nowhere
man right like there's nobody out here
i've been like
not fully desensitized to the masks yet
because i've been living kind of out
here working from home and i'll see
videos of people these crowds of people
and they're all wearing masks and it
makes me angry like
when i see obese people that are eating
bad food when like it's like just
they're like and i say get that same
kind of like
like helpless rage or hopeless like what
have we become
why are we doing this and so i'm like
and it's like
shuddering i had a buddy in miami uh
texting me today
that he was getting into an uber and the
driver
lost his mind on him because he wasn't
double masked
and he started and he started screaming
he said the driver started screaming
that there's been a presidential order
and
president biden has put this down and
everyone has to be double-masked
he threw him out of the car we're not
double masking
why not triple masking virtual masks
oh i got good news i got really good
news i don't know if i should announce
it
you made a mask that has two masks in
one no those space helmet
astronaut helmets they made officially
got sent out a couple days ago
have you seen them no it is this glass
dome
that you and you put the thing over your
head and it and it rests on your neck
like bioshock
like bioshock it's got fans in it
no it's got air filters the big brothers
dude and
i'm like there's like the guy who
invented it you know look more power to
the guy for trying to work on inventing
something
but everyone said the same thing when i
tweeted about it they said what happens
if you sneeze
it's just glass in front of you so you
like sneeze and crush and then it's just
like everywhere like
what do you do quickly lift it up and go
there and spray you know
you're dead from cove dude i'm so
excited to get these it's gonna be
something you ordered a bunch of them i
ordered two
nice i would too so we're gonna we'll
film with them and we'll like we'll do
we'll we'll go out wearing them and see
how people react it'll be hilarious
we'll be like at a restaurant just
sitting there like with like how do you
eat how do you eat
well well they had a theory that you
could put food through the opposite
right here's the plan here's the plan i
want to go to a restaurant where's the
healthy way
and i want to get someone else with me
and we'll order food but just sit there
staring
at me not moving and the food just
sitting in front of us
and not touching you like a third person
with a camera on the other table
just for 20 minutes to see how people
react to us just like blank blank faces
just sitting there with these things on
not eating okay or or we can actually
take the food and just like hit the
glass
and then just like we'll have to take
out like youtube ad space and run that
can we put ian in a bubble
for some reason i see like bubble boy
popping in there coming in
as long as we get a bubble yeah let's do
it let's let's you know we should do
just going down the sidewalk in your
bubble yeah we should we should no we
should get one of those bubbles at like
the violence what's that band that does
that the flaming lips the flaming lips
you have to be extremely upset and
intolerant when you
know people who are unbubbled yeah yes
where is your bubble a lot a lot of
people say haven't you read the science
a lot of people say that in the future
it's gonna it's going to be like
fahrenheit 451 brave new world 1984.
i say they're all wrong the future is
going to be like bubble boy
yeah remember that movie did you see
that yeah that's the future
you didn't see it no no i'm pretty funny
all right all right we gotta take more
super chats remember the seinfeld
episode
we gotta remember that acme product says
i'm shocked that time story was
published it's too good to be true it's
too perfect
when was the last time you saw the media
describe how the wealthy and powerful
conspire
i have an ominous feeling about it like
some sort of trap thoughts
my thoughts are that they feel so
confident in their victory knowing that
nothing can be done about this
that the after everything they feared
the the the worst thing that happened
was a bunch of like middle-aged trump
supporters
bumble it you know be bewildered and
befuddled walking around the capitol
building and then leaving
it's like that was it who who will go
after those people
although their nicest were thrown out
like what i think they feel
confident with what people all the
people in the cabal
that they're talking about like well
look look in their minds who's going to
come out who's coming after us
let's just make it known and then we can
just keep doing it over and over again
and this is the test
there there the story from the call is
not about court cases it's about how
they changed the rules the year leading
into the election which is what i've
been saying over and over but like
anyone that would what are you saying is
there's no there's no check
right there's no check on any of this so
why not take credit for it now
well so uh remember we're this didn't
run until two weeks
after the inauguration yep there's no
possible checkpoints they're they're
they're really testing us no i think
they're testing the world right now
well as michael malus said some very bad
people got data on what people are
willing to tolerate yep
that's michael mallis's tolerance test
well and my response is
it kind of feels like they're hitting us
as much as like they're they're doing
things to us to see like how we respond
as if we're like mice in a lot in a maze
like if if there was like a
huge backlash and then people started
going after legals they just like no no
it wasn't true
that time thing wasn't true yep it was
fake news and everyone fell for it
today they're like let's tell them we
fortified it and then tell them we're
gonna drone bomb them for believing it
that's literally what they're doing
today one of my favorite memes from i
think it was
at some point in 2020 where it was uh it
was uh
the lizards who controlled the
simulation apologize and say they're
going to turn everything back to 2015.
we're sorry
we just wanted to see how you would
react all right we got a couple more we
got uh
let's see oh i got cut off there we go
tommy
dorgarian says shout out for my company
level ride concepts in salem oregon
25 member here amazing content thank you
for being a member at timcast.com thank
you
we have another one here what we got
blob monsters as i want blob monster
says i want to apologize to ian for
being mean to him
i listened to him last night talking
about his troubles he has a product of
his abuse
uh thank you all right well there you go
i guess you're probably right about that
daniel maxwell says i see you got jack
posobik on
the man who could not meet the challenge
of getting the receipts on a person when
he was challenged to do so
he still does good journalism what is
that about i
no idea not too vague i have the
receipts on everybody yeah pork which
has a question for you jack
jack how can we hold true to our oaths
usaf vet
at this point it feels like any action
taken would be suicide
they've done everything possible to
disarm us keep us from communicating
and eliminate our income and it all
seems to be accelerating
i would say that i come to this from the
perspective of look
when i took my oath to serve the
military serve the country that he's
referring to the
the military oath you know we swear
enough to serve the constitution and not
any particular government or politician
but now i'm a family guy i've i've got
my wife i've got my kids
and i wake up every day and i think
i live for them now that i live to
make sure that they're going to be okay
and that they're going to be set up for
success going forward and
my my time is starting to end my time i
mean i'm not an old guy or anything but
how do you see that i'm 36. so you see
that
but you see that your your your children
will eventually you know kind of but
look you've got
over a million twitter followers you
know you you put out information
people follow that you know what i mean
like you're you're doing something
that's having a serious impact
right right and people understand that
if if you really want
to right you know going back though you
know he was asking me personal questions
i was answering
pretty personal way but as far as the
actual turning back the system this is a
30-year project it took a very long time
for things to get this bad and i hope
people understand that you can't have
you're not just going to find one
esoteric law
and walk it into a courtroom somewhere
and get one judge it's not going to be
like that folks it's going to be
a long slog we're going to chip away at
all of this corruption
that's how it works it's never going to
be you know
you wake up one day and it all goes away
i think there's actually one really
simple solution
and it's that not enough people in
whatever space we're in
are speaking up that's all it is the the
reason they control the narrative the
reason why so many ignorant people
remain ignorant is because too many
people are scared of being canceled and
won't
speak up yeah there's not enough people
doing what you are doing and tweeting or
any one of us in tweeting and putting
out videos and putting out stories
there are a lot of regular people who
hear things and know things and aren't
engaging in the culture the same way the
left does
the left goes on twitter and brigades
and mass reports and flags people they
get jobs at news organizations and they
take them over and then they push this
narrative
and not enough people are countering
that that's it we're like nodes on a
network and
every human is a node and if the node
doesn't light up when it receives the
information to pass the
out the the transaction breaks down so
we need to light up
and it is as simple in a lot of ways
it's just retweeting or sharing
information a lot of times with your own
explanation yeah and i always say this
to people as well that look if you've
got a normie job out there
don't use your real name on social media
please for the love of god right you
know
keep being out there be smart you know
don't don't have this
you know chest beating moment of i need
to say this on facebook or
cara my boss says no it matters what
your boss thinks you don't get fired
don't get in trouble for
some political thing but at the same
time be out there and if you can find a
specific instance
where you can get one person to wake up
and read this time magazine article
print it out for people i wish they
would print it out
and put it on every seat at the
impeachment trial which is coming up
next week by the way and say look
they threw this guy off of social media
for saying these things
they claim that him saying this was an
incitement to violence but when time
magazine
comes out and molly ball prints the
exact same
uh fact i said trump was right he
exactly she said trump was right
it says it it says in a way true it is a
floating
personing of something look when did you
did you see that mark elias the
democratic lawyer is now arguing the
voting machines right
he actually lost that by the way he
actually lost that i just saw the
headline lost that case
good it's absurd that the democrats
would scream trump's lying and then make
the same argument
i'm i'm not surprised and there's no
point and there's no point
in in going oh it's a double standard we
know we know they have no shame we know
they cheat we know they lie
now what boring yeah now what well
we need to realize that they roll by
fear consent and self-censorship a lot
of what they do is to incentivize
you not knowing the rules so then they
could have this chilling effect we don't
know what we can and cannot say on
youtube many
other times the rules are vague we don't
know why people get punished we don't
know why people get demonetized
censored kicked off deleted off social
media we don't know there's no official
conversation or dialogue and i think
it's done on purpose so we keep
everyone in line because everyone's
waiting until they get hit some people
get hit for the most
obvious reasons some people get hit for
the most non-obvious reasons and you're
left here wondering and confused and
scared and that's exactly how they want
you
all right so we uh we got another one
from gareth green he says i cover my
ears i close my eyes i still hear your
voice and it's telling me lies linda
thompson
i have a mixture of anger and despair
today partly because of the obvious but
also andrew sullivan's beautiful piece
on the woke attack on the classics read
it
it was really hard for me to work all
day because i woke up to seeing this
story
and it was picking up steam and i read
it and i couldn't think about anything
else the time magazine story saying yeah
we did it
we did it so what and i'm like okay
i gotta i gotta produce a bunch of
different stories and i sit down and
read the news and i couldn't think of
anything else
and so i'm like man i'm not gonna do
just i actually wanted to break this
down
and running was something you were
saying but i think it'll go
to this question so intelligent services
there's three types of operations
there's
um overt covert and clandestine and
people get covert and clandestine
confused a lot they use them
interchangeably they're not actually
interchangeable
so overt operations everybody knows what
that is that's you know we invaded
somewhere and here they are and they're
walking on the street they're invading
covert operations means uh
0.30 is probably the biggest you know
most easy example of that that's a
black op they went in they got bin laden
they got out right but everybody knows
who did it everybody
yeah after the fact right knows what
happened knows who did it
a clandestine operation and this is
where cia
and predominantly operates this is where
an operation
takes place a change is made somewhere
in the world
and yet no knowledge of the operation
exists there's
you don't even know that an operation
took place and they measure success
by getting in getting out and nobody
knows that an operation ever happened
right so that when i read the time
magazine piece i said oh this was a
clandestine op that they're now coming
forward on
so they're now coming forward to claim
credit to say and
different people that i worked with used
to take pride in that they used to say
for
for the deed not the glory that actually
used to be a phrase for the deed not the
glory
because you were doing something even
though you knew you weren't getting
credit for it
for these folks they want the glory
remember when biden said he had the
largest
voter fraud organization in history or
whatever
not freudian they said in the time
magazine piece that they recruited
armies of poll workers
one thing you actually didn't mention
yet act towards the end of that time
magazine piece
they point out that towards the end of
election day they decided to not
and i'm paraphrasing they decided to not
send
activists into the streets and people
were asking
why didn't anything happen after
november 3rd because
we decided not to send the signal to our
activists to not go out and march so
are they talking about like the left
wing
antifa blm groups
that you know people always kind of
suspect
sort of pop up and are switched on and
off at certain times
that are you actually admitting that you
do control those groups and the timing
of when and where they commit their
actions
yeah speaking of have there been many
antifa and black lives matter riots
relative to what was before january 5th
yes
uh portland seattle yeah the main part
but that's about it
what would have happened if trump would
have won what kind of protest
if trump and that well i think that what
they're actually saying in the time
magazine piece
if you know the inverse of what they're
saying is had
trump had a greater turnout then they
would have activated
these marchers these militants these
activists
to go out into the streets and to use
the vernacular
incited uh people going out and
contesting the election
let's read some more super chats here
we've got to protect democracy want to
be very clear to protect
legitimately fortify like a multivitamin
that's right we have mr hunt here
mike says russia hoax doesn't lead to
violence but questioning the integrity
of the election does
we absolutely 100 live in a fascist
state now those that claim to have been
fighting against it were fighting for it
that's a fact like i i called out some
of these people earlier today
the people who were cheering on antifa
destroying small businesses and
attacking regular americans and then
cheering on the military coming in and
occupying dc
it's like okay if you're cheering for
the destruction of the working class and
then supporting the establishment
machine sending the military to dc
like you're in favor of the authority
dude like what do you think's going on
the uh the berlin wall for the entire
time i'm sorry i'm sorry
the anti-fascist protection i was gonna
say it yeah i was gonna say yeah for the
uh i get into this and doing an antifa
book a little plug um pretty soon here
but
that for the entirety of its of its
history was known
in official documentation as the
anti-fascist rampart
of east germany oh okay you were that
was your point that was my point i
thought you were going to be talking
about the berlin wall but i wanted you
to call it
right it's official name right that the
anti-fascist protection so
anti-fascism actually became sort of the
state religion of east germany
and that they sort of morphed
everything that the third reich did into
west germany and then in their telling
the united states
and the uk and canada were supportive
of this continuation of fascism that
they were just a different
type of fascism they were capitalist
social fascism this gets into
uh the actual rise of antifa and the
communist party in weimar germany they
just
never stopped actually saying those
beliefs right this
all goes back so anti-fascism from its
start
was not actually about being
anti-fascist it's anarchal communist
right all right we got one for you jack
this is this one's a serious question
from
david bowie's i'm not gonna read the
full name he says for agent posa poso
i said that foreign terror org that
antifa was training with
ypg where cia assets and guarded uh and
guarded our military
installations you blocked me on twitter
can you please unblock me or educate me
why i'm wrong
uh well they perhaps i would have to go
back and look at the contest of maybe
it looked like you were coming back at
me you know uh for something like that
i'd
obviously look at the exact interaction
but it is truthful
that ypg this was an organization a
curtis militant organization
that did have u.s support at one point
were also
on the other side turning around and
financing
funding and training antifa who had come
over from western germany and north
america
to participate in their operations and
one of them this guy daniel allen turner
was just arrested in florida for
planning an attack on the florida
capitol on inauguration day 2021 he
also he said that you know we're we
still need to investigate this
he states that he was part of the
militant um
gun the armed guards up at chase in
seattle during the summer of 2020
and from his own twitter feed says that
he was involved in one of the shootings
that took place
in chaz wow so this is a guy that again
going off of all of his own statements
says that he was in ypg that he was in
syria that he came back
that he used what he learned on the
battlefield in chaz then
finally got picked up by the fbi
planning an attack on the florida
capital
wow here's something interesting pims
the great says two-man crew-manned
machine guns come in five five
six seven six two and three three eight
no there you go
three three eight or do you mean three
oh eight no three three and seven six
are basically the same
thing i guess you know i was some guy
was telling me never to put a 308 and a
762 because the pressure
is different but a lot of people were
like ah it's the same thing
i don't care yes and no
huh conclusive thanks everyone
okay full full mental alchemist says tim
saitama is a great character but moomin
rider is the best one on one punch
man moomin has no powers at all but
still does everything he can to be a
hero regardless of fame
batman versus superman that is that that
is correct moomin writer is one of the
best heroes probably
i'd say saitama's my favorite character
but you know what yeah i think moomin
writer
are you guys familiar with one punch man
no no
very simple just of it one punch man is
basically
an all-powerful god like that the theme
of the anime is that he's this like
un you know he's just like the silly
looking guy
but he can defeat anybody no one can
stop him he can jump to the moon he's
just all-powerful
and he's kind of dumb but uh he's a good
guy and he wants to be this great hero
but they kind of treat him poorly
moomin writer is a class c hero who's
just a guy who rides a bike around and
wants to be a hero
but the point is he gets into a fight
with this really big monster and is
being beaten mercilessly but he refuses
to stop because he's trying to defend
other people
stop them from getting killed so even
though he knows he's going to die he
he does it whereas saitama just walks up
and flicks the guy and you know he's got
no fear
superman versus batman it's a good point
huh
yeah yeah i know that's great man of
course it's good coldlock's production
says star wars was about watching out
for corruption and fascism and
government manipulation
and when disney got a hold of it they
tried to feminize and corrupt it to
their narrative
eddie johnson asks what does jack think
of snowden
you know snowden's someone that i would
have to say that i've i've had a journey
on assange 2
really that you know i'm a guy who you
know people say are you part of the deep
state to sobic and i was like well
you know of course maybe you know you
know
i i i was on the side that was doing the
drone strikes right to what luke was
saying that and now i'm here and so
i do think that if you break the law
that there are going to be consequences
so i understand that you know from the
leaking perspective
but at the same time the amount of stuff
that that guy was able to
expose and the transparency that he
provided to people
has proven to be a public service 100
yeah
uh razio says question to any trekkie on
the set
me and my bro discussed this topic last
night and was wondering what you guys
who you guys would pick if you were to
start your own crew who would be your
go-to analytical science officer
data or seven of nine and why oh data
obviously
guys yeah of course why wouldn't you
want me andrew elon musk
what'd you guys familiar with seven of
nine oh of the three data
uh a data or seven seven seven of nine
is one person that's the girl with the
she's the board former borg former
forward data hands down who's the other
one
spock no data or seven of nine i'm still
confused
so here's here's the most important
thing if you guys have seen the the
episode
where uh in the next generation they get
trapped in the titans rift
you guys know this one of course you
know this yeah and there's
on the other side of the rift because
they're these two the crew is trapped
they're being bombarded and they don't
realize this with telepathic rays
preventing rem sleep
right so over time they're slowly going
insane and as they get no
they go to sleep but they don't actually
get dreams and rem cycles data they
start breaking down
but data is unaffected so because of
data
they end up surviving for the most part
and because of troy who is partially
telepathic and could translate in her
dreams
the message they released the uh the
what was the
hydrogen which interacted with the
fictitious star trek element of
calendenium which caused the explosion
wiping out the rift which they then
ripped through
i know a lot about star trek so wow wow
you chose an artificial intelligence
data yes
i think there's something well because
he he's he's he's he's a safety net you
know creating a
yeah ai safety net it just needs to be
free software so we can watch it write
its own code
anti-fragile yeah it was cool though i
like at the end when uh
like everyone's basically on the verge
of dying because they've like they're
losing their minds
data is totally fine and then he orders
the captain to bed he's like he's like
as my ass my
my last order as acting captain is to
order you to bed sir and
picard's like oh thank you data and then
he goes to bed 25th amendment
yeah 25th amendment you know they really
brought that up because of commodore
right
which one seems like it but the reason
that everybody isn't talking about the
20 this is so obvious by the way
the reason that they've been seeding
this narrative that even in the
the last weeks of the trump
administration that they were talking
about oh 25th amendment regarding the
20th amendment
the 20th amendment is not about if you
don't like somebody you want to
know that's impeachment right and he is
being impeached um the 25th amendment is
about
mental capacity mental capability and
the idea is supposed to be that um you
know if you if you're if you have some
medical condition
and you you know you're not uh you know
deceased you're you're still alive
but you can't you function right then
like if we had a president who
thought the movies what was that what
was that movie with with the
war games yeah if we had a president who
thought war games was a real thing
right a lot of this a lot of these laws
were written
in after the kennedy assassination right
because they were thinking of
different permutations of what could
happen what if this part that's why we
have so many lines out of the line of
succession
so many degrees of this and then this
was also brought up as something
of well what if he was just
incapacitated right and so
but i think that the reason that they're
talking about it is because they want to
use it on joe biden at some point
i agree of course of course yep troy
dunham says
i've graduated from an ian hater to an
ian fanboy ian when did you get red
pilled
2004 i think
oh wow it was about like loose loose
change i think you actually worked on
that didn't you yeah yeah
so that was back in the week we have we
have some zeitgeist that whole era of
like internet video red pilling in the
early days
we uh someone uh gareth green is giving
us a little correction he says chechia
was formerly known as the czech republic
yes and before that part of
czechoslovakia
and before that bohemia and moravia part
of the austrian empire couldn't place it
so i actually knew somebody who
identified as bohemian
because their family emigrated from
bohemia right
to the u.s and so when i was like asking
who they're like oh yeah where your
parents what is your ethnicity and
they're like well we're from america but
we're all bohemian
and i was like oh and then i'm like
where's that and everyone's like there's
no such place
i'm like yeah there was a long time ago
and the people who were there identified
as bohemian
left and retained that as their you know
heritage even though it's totally
different now you know
it's like that in um uh for some a lot
of like like polls and ukrainians that
came over before poland got their
independence back there was this
um they would refer to their region as
ruthenia yeah
the ruthenians right even though that's
if you look today that's not a province
it's it never even was like a really
defined area um there's no kingdom of
ruthenia but
it was just sort of this this phrase and
so when i was going through some of the
census documents of my own family you'll
see
from ruthenia but because that's what
they put but that's
you know it's never actually been a
place hey clarification i gotta rebuild
like end of 2006.
it was right after i started making
youtube videos all the people would
comment they'd be like you need to learn
about the federal reserve you need to
watch
loose change you need to see aaron russo
and he was like
sorry freedom to fascism aaron russo
great guy yeah awesome
that was a great reason peace all right
let's see we got a ton of super chats
but i'll
we'll we'll try and read a little bit
more drake d says 762
by 51 nato and 50 bmg m2 machines are
crew served or mounted
however 338 norma mag in the works
uh is in the works to supplement 50 bmg
m2 crew served weapons
338 nm is also significantly lighter per
round
is that good good thing or a bad thing
because i mean 50 bmg those are those
are building destroyers you mow it
building down and just
you know what i mean have you seen how
big those things are
yeah when luke came in and he hold the
belt yeah when lou came in with the belt
how do you get this thing imagine the
opt i just imagine the optics
of a military occupation with crew
served weapons
jeez in our nation's capital but then
people being told
this is for your own good and these are
the same people that want to ban your
guns with hr 127 and i looked into it
yesterday there's so much more stuff
that we didn't cover yeah if you have a
50 bmg
uh like piece of ammunition minimum 10
years in jail
yeah yeah so that's that's nuts eduardo
selena says tim i asked about the game
of skate last time
you have the crazy flat ground butt i
got them switch let's do it love the
show man oh you think i don't got switch
bro i can nollie hard flip late flip
i can nollie hard flip late 180 i can
switch hardflip late when eddie and
switch hard flip late flip bring it on
brother
ain't got game all right i got switch
switch i can do basically everything
switch
no joke you got you got you got a mouth
son
you think you come in here bring that
bring that skate smack top
calm down but i'm i'm almost 35. i don't
i don't skate as hard as i used to but
you know
i definitely i'm i'm focusing more on
mini ramp because i didn't skate many i
i skated a bit when i was younger
now i'm having a lot more more fun
skating mini it's good fun
i got a six foot half pipe it's great
let's see publius the good
says so so you are saying that you are
fully aware the dnc committed a coup and
actually overthrew the us government
against the will of the people
and your answer is you're a family man
oathbreaker period
coward whoa yikes who are we talking to
here jack
wow buddy go go army dot com man go if
you want if you want to
you want to sign up you want to serve
you want to go over there kick in some
doors
go army go army was it go with dot mil i
think right well that sounds like
somebody oath keeper wow
you know also i just like to say too
whatever federal agent just wrote that
he's trying to get me to say something
like you're glowing a little bit too
hard right now buddy
no it comes down to this like we
understand what you're trying to do
and for anybody out there who i
understand the frustration i do
understand the frustration
and i understand the anger and i
understand the
we got ocean 11 right what are we
supposed to do about that
there is no easy answer there is
it's peaceful persuasive and resourceful
it's this
it's this exactly it's what we're doing
right now it's culture building
that's why we're talking about starting
a vlog and we've been you know working
towards doing this but getting the
website up as a priority
and that's why we want to look here's
the way i explain it we just talked
about a little about skateboarding are
you just talking about having strong
families what's that gonna do
yeah whatever right right right right
come on are you kidding me
parallel systems there's there's there's
a very there's a well-known skateboarder
who puts a ton of videos up it's like
there's actually a couple skateboarders
they put up videos on instagram and on
the mini ramp
the mini ramp is painted to be the
gadsden flag and so i've watched these
videos of some of the best mini ramp
skating i've ever seen
from these people and i laugh and i'm
like yeah gadsden mini ramp
what do you think happens when a 14 year
old kid sees this pro
doing an amazing trick and they think
that's so cool and they see the gadsden
flag
then they go to school and the teacher
says this is white supremacy
they go what no way dude my favorite
skateboarders do the same thing they're
not racist exactly you're lying to me
exactly
that's the culture building stuff i'm
talking about speaking up
being proud of what you believe and look
you know it is a difficult philosophical
philosophical question i remember when i
was a little kid i saw a science said
stand up for what you believe in
and i was like racists believe in awful
stuff you want them to stand up
they do okay well i'll stand up to
oppose that so
literally whatever you believe if you
really believe it you'll stand by which
used to be the standard right by the way
which used to be the standard
that if you know the answer to bad
speech was more speech
good right better speech that you add
speech
to that and then people can decide on
their own what is better right this is
why
these issues that we talk about today
where and actually you were talking
earlier about the 90s conservatives
versus like millennial conservatives and
the week.com just did a big piece on bar
they called it bar stool conservatism
where you know it's not the conservatism
of the 1990s anymore it's not jerry
falwell
that it's it's yeah there's culture wars
but they're not on the same lines it's a
different
you know from a military perspective a
different delta than where you would be
having those battlegrounds before it is
about speech codes
it's about political correctness going
crazy and how it's getting into our
corporate culture it's in our
our schools et cetera et cetera all
right well we'll take just a couple more
here
amber emily says captain archer or cisco
also post
cisco 100 yeah cisco no question no
questions what the hell are these
questions
dude i have no idea cisco was though i
like though
i do like captain archer i i will throw
some i know captain archer gets crapped
on a lot
i know that to be mean can we talk about
the
yeah no no no no i guess not cisco was
legit jake paul
but cisco obviously cisco logan no no
jake jake or logan pick one jake paul or
logan paul jake paul
or ben askren ben ben
in a boxing match yeah ben yep you're
here to hear first
well that's that's the destiny i'm gonna
go with ben askren even though he
doesn't follow me on twitter and the yes
that is how i judge you there was one
more part of this question that said
also poso
where is the most patriotic place to get
an mba internship
to get an mbo does liberty have uh
have mbas i i'd have to look it up the
last question
and the most important one from levitt
levy hint
says ian how long have you been growing
out your hair i'm on a year and i can
finally put it in a bun i think
four or five five years maybe wow wow
nice long time
um i like the question super chats where
you ask us to all answer a question
yes there are a lot of you trying to
trim as you go
no i haven't trimmed it at all like
samson i would think it would almost
like it would be longer
but like i'll pull it and like pull
pieces out from like here's one there
so like it never gets too long i don't
know it's curly in the shedding next
time
yeah i'm shedding pieces of balls all
right we'll do one more we got super
zena says just watch your
last podcast on the tragedy involving
that man the first lesson my father
taught me was
don't start fights because you don't
know who will end it yeah
yeah that story about the is that the
snow thing yeah that was i mean that's
i i always just walk away yeah yeah just
walk
away if they want to walk away just
de-escalate do everything right okay
it's okay to walk away there's i mean
whenever i have these conversations with
people
it's you know oh well he said to me and
i've got look it's i get it
it's it's it's especially if this is a
problem that men have
this is a problem that men have where we
are taught from an early age never back
down if you back down that's showing
weakness
you're never supposed to look like a
victim someone disrespects you you
have to throw down and make sure that
you do what what do you get from that
but you know what's your what's your
what's your reward for that yeah we're
not guerrilla i don't i don't i don't
know if it's the asian in me but
my my upbringing was victory was the
most important aspect
and the ninja was you you like i
explained this to people
the ninja doesn't walk into the palace
like and try and fight all the guards in
front
to confront the the emperor of the
feudal lord they sneak in around the
back they disguise themselves as a
common person
it is a very western it is a very
western
way of thinking i think about like the
stereotypical depictions of
like victory has to be on the
battlefield right i it's
too you're so for single combat crossing
swords right
right whereas you know and you had the
samurai
but the way i've always approached it i
told this to the occupy activists i was
like
do you think you're going to walk up to
the palace guards fight them and win and
walk up to the next
wave of guards and fight him and win or
do you think the ninja who crawls in
from the roof and then you know on the
ceiling setting up his escape routes and
planning some months in advance is going
to win
you have to be strategic about it that
means i
i've never experienced a loss of pride
from purposefully choosing to walk away
from conflict or a fight or some kind of
when i had
that uh lincoln statue altercation over
the summer where
the antifa guy got right in my face um
there were a lot of people who said jack
why didn't you swing on him right he was
clearly in your space he was you know
like smacking me at one point they tried
to push me down
you know why why not just take a swing
at him why not just take him
take him out like that because again
strategically thinking
ahead i know how that's gonna look
right and this is a guy who's smaller
than me it's their plan
they want me to do that and there is
more
strength and there is more power in the
victory of saying
i'm going to keep my hands by my side
and no matter what you say to me no
matter what you do to me
i am not going to react that photo was
the legit victory so if those aren't
familiar
there's a photo of jack thank you
standing in front of this antifa guy was
all angry and
you just looked stern that's it you you
look like
i'm just not like you're it's stern
you're not angry
i'm doing the prayer to st michael in my
head there you go yeah so i had a
similar situation in boston where a guy
got in my face
and i just was like all right tighten
the abs clench the jaws like bring it on
buddy i'm not going to swing on you i
don't know what you're doing yeah
exactly right
and there's there's strength in that
they're strengthened knowing that if i
need to defend myself yeah okay sure i
will
but if you're just doing this why i do
also magic like i'll think it's calm you
just think it instead of say it
the the photograph if they pause for a
moment then you can do whatever you want
it's all about information war right
that's why i said the photograph was the
victory
they wanted you to hit a guy who was
smaller than you and say jack pasok
showed up and started attacking
right then cnn and jake taper be out
there conservative reporter for one
american news jackpot
attacked an anti-racist protester in
front of the lincoln statue
and then and then you have como back
this guy's smaller than him what's he
doing
pick on me huh come on and then you know
cuomo would like raise his arms or
whatever that's what they wanted
instead they looked pathetic and weak
going
at you who was just like i'm cool as a
cucumber bro you know
come at me bro right on okay ladies and
gentlemen go to timcast.com become a
member for exclusive members only
content
maybe we're going out to uh uh we're
going out to the range on sunday
and so we didn't get a whole lot of
footage last time maybe we'll do more
there's business involvement i got some
footage
luke got some footage there's some fun
stuff with the 50 the 50 bmg breach
loading which is uh which was
loud it shut my camera off because i was
standing to the left of luke when he
fired
my phone just turned off so is that a
shock wave can we can we get i
final answer and then i'm like and i'm
like okay okay tim your turn he's like
no
we gotta look at the time yeah oh man we
saw it
but man uh yeah so anyway we're we'll
get some footage
and uh we'll see what we do but if you
want to get exclusive exclusive members
only content we got a ton up right now
we got full bonus episodes about life
after death
ufos and stuff like that and trafficking
teamcast.com become a member help us be
that shield and safety net in the event
they try to
they try to take us down don't forget to
follow me on instagram twitter
minds at tim cast my other youtube
channels are youtube.comtimcast
youtube.comcastnews
this show is live monday through friday
at 8 00 pm if you're listening on the
podcast to give us a shout out give us a
good review and if you're not check it
out because it helps us out
and uh seriously thanks everybody's
becoming a member jack do you want to
shout anything out
uh you check us out one american news
twitter at uh
jackpotsobic i will have my antifa book
coming in a couple of weeks now it's
called antifa
inside the black block my stories
you can also go to antifamovie.com and
check out the documentary we did 60
minutes
all about the history of antifa how they
come from and where they're going
one of the quick things i wanted to say
during the super chats is just really
quickly don't let them take away your
happiness and your peace i want to thank
msnbc for inspiring me to bring back my
old
t-shirt i think it was my first ever
shirt that said don't
drone me bro that is now officially back
yes on the bestpoliticalshirts.com it
was during the obama era where it was
pretty much
you know created and now it's still
relevant full circle who would have
thought
and uh yeah the best political
shorts.com i release youtube videos on
the youtube channel we
are changed i'm an independent uh
youtube channel still somehow existing
mainly because of you and i want to
thank you guys for watching and
participating and being a part of the
conversation on my channel it means a
lot to me thank you
we are changed the best political shirt
stuck out there i will personally say i
love the material i love the way it fits
it's very warm
very snug i was pleasantly surprised
uh you can also follow me online at ian
crossland uh twitter
youtube facebook instagram and mines i'm
also streaming on twitch twitch.tv slash
ian crossland it's hot
very cool see you there and i am sour
patch lids i am on
twitter and minds.com and i am real sour
patch lids on
instagram and gab because someone stole
my username anyway
thanks for hanging out everybody we'll
be back it's today friday yeah
friday friday uh so we'll be back monday
at 8 pm thanks for bringing out we'll
see you then bye guys
you